make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
so what I wanted to do here is have a
discussion about Marvel's first black
superhero the blue marvel Adam Brashear
however before we get into this video I
want to let people know ahead of time
that some of the phrases used in the
story to describe african-americans and
other non-white cultures may be
considered a little offensive and while
the intention is not to be malicious I'm
keeping these phrases in this video as
they serve to establish a significance
of both the story itself as well as the
perception the world had of blue Marvel
and the way he viewed himself
so Adam Brashear was created by Kevin
Griffo who was also the mastermind
behind both the underworld and I
frankenstein series as well as a writer
for Superman Batman and others in an
interview with the source a digital and
print media hub for news relating to
urban music african-american issues
youth culture and politics
Corvo had stated that the character of
Adam Brashear was as much a reflection
of himself as he was a wholly new
character for Marvel Comics what I mean
here is that as a graduate of Howard
University Kevin Griffo sport folio
consists of a stint as a football player
as well as a bachelor's degree in
microbiology with minors in chemistry
and psychology in addition to a master's
in genetic engineering furthermore as an
african-american born in 1962 and
growing up during the early days of the
civil rights movement and his youth
Kevin Grebo experienced racism from
various directions and as such folded
these concepts over into his writing of
the blue Marvel character in addition to
this during the same interview the
question was asked about his view of
diversity and comics regarding
superheroes of color created by writers
of color and his answer Griffo had
stated that to him while there were
multiple black artists there were very
few writers who are black while he
acknowledged this isn't necessarily
indicative of a systemic issue of racism
the problem arises when writers create
content based on their own personal
experiences as a result the most
prominent black superheroes and Marvel
Comics in particular are Sam Wilson
Black Panther and storm only one of whom
could be considered a wildly powerful
being and in effort to rectify this
grave Oh had sought to create a black
superhero that as he put it could sit at
the table of Superman Martian Manhunter
Shazam and the century and hold his own
as a character that could rise to almost
any occasion and save the world but also
had a level of intelligence that could
rival Marvel's smartest beings including
Reed Richards Tony Stark and Amadeus Cho
as a result in November of 2008 he
released a semi period five-part
miniseries titled The Legend of blue
Marvel which took a page from Paul Ginga
Sanjay leads this century and introduced
Adam Brashear as a superhero who existed
prior to the dawn of characters like
black panther spider-man and the x-men
but left the scene due to the culture of
racism in the United States during the
early 1960s having said that the legend
of blue Marvel bounces back and forth
between the 1960s and the events
immediately following civil war
and the death of Captain America in that
during this time Tony Stark is director
of shield Carol Danvers leads the
Avengers branch off team called The
Mighty Avengers and the roster of the
main Avengers team itself consists of
the century Robert Reynolds Tony Stark
Ares the Greek god of war Black Widow
Yellow Jacket Hank Pym and she-hulk in
the opening events of this story the
group is in the midst of a battle with a
being named ante man someone who will be
explored further in the story but the
significance of this battle is that it
serves to set the stage for the coming
events by establishing a kind of blue
Marvel is the only one who can save us
idea and that the Avengers are being
completely ravaged by anti man the
century for example is it being on par
with the Hulk even in his angriest form
but against anti man he poses no true
threat and is easily taken down in
addition to this Ares is an Olympian and
the son of Zeus and Hera with prodigious
skill in battle while his strength is
less than both Thor and the century he
along with she-hulk Carol Danvers and
everyone else is virtually useless here
and so with Iron Man demanding to know
why the anti man is here both his
motives and the first mission of blue
Marvel come when he responds that his
purpose is to brief salvation to the
planet Earth and that not even blue
Marvel was able to stop him when the two
had previously fought and so as a battle
comes to a close the indication here is
an ant-man was on a timetable with a
limit to how long he could exist or at
the very least fight under these
conditions which becomes apparent when
he effectively dissolves and fades away
now recovering from the battle Griffo
continues to tease us with the power of
blue Marvel when the century comments on
how powerful anti man was and that he
has never experienced a being on such a
scale furthermore Tony Stark pulls the
group together arguing that because such
a being exists the only way for them to
defeat him is to understand who he is
and where his power comes from now from
here we jump back to 1962 with our first
depiction of blue marvel himself in a
battle with the anti man now the
reasoning behind the anti man's actions
largely remain ambiguous here and that
the statements between the two of them
as a do battle indicate that an T man
intends a larger end of the world kind
of scenario with blue Marvel doing what
he can to stop him furthermore as he's
depicted here blue Marvel has all the
hallmarks of a traditional hero and that
he refuses to give up in the midst of
the battle
he does what he can to keep innocence
protected and he also attempts to talk
anti man down from his rampage however
as a true villain anti man is the
antithesis of blue Marvel and that he's
unwavering from his goal of presumed
genocide and has no regard for the lives
of the innocent people around him
now the reason I'm drawing your
attention to this is that the way Kevin
groove ode depicts blue Marvel here is
that he's not an antihero blurring the
line between right and wrong and instead
he is by all standards of measurement a
genuine hero and so the dichotomies
between blue Marvel and an T man come to
a head when we learn that according to
an T man humanity is a victim of his own
viciousness callousness and warmongering
while there are good individuals out
there in the mind of an T man all humans
are the same and that if humanity won't
correct the error of its own morality
then he intends to force them to by
wiping them all out now all of this
again comes to a head as the to battle
with blue Marvel coming out victorious
but the world also learning that he's a
black man at this point Griffo begins to
move the story away from the basic
premise of superheroes battling one
another to focusing on the fallout of
America learning that the most powerful
superhero in the world is an
african-american and picking up with
Robert McNamara the real-world Secretary
of Defense under President John F
Kennedy during the 1960's alongside
President Kennedy himself and the rest
of his defense cabinet were provided the
background of blue Marvel in that his
name is Adam Brashear he graduated at
the top of his class from Cornell with a
PhD in electrical engineering and
theoretical physics with McNamara even
going so far as to state that he's not
your average colored from here the focus
switches to his power where we're told
that his actions have saved the world on
multiple occasions
in one instance he knocked a meteor the
size of Arkansas off its collision
course with earth during the Cuban
Missile Crisis of 1962 when the United
States and Russia almost went to war
over the placement of Soviet nuclear
weapons in Cuba as part of the u.s.
naval blockade around Cuba the USS
Enterprise was damaged by a Russian
submarine at which point blue Marvel
carried the ship from the Atlantic back
to its port in the Newport News ship
these escapades combined with the fact
that he had prevented the premature
detonation of the Polaris nuclear
ballistics missile during the famous
1962 failure meant that as far as
McNamara was concerned as the Secretary
of Defense
Basheer represents a level of power they
can't contain and that if the fledgling
civil rights movement were to rally him
to their cause the result would be a
super-powered african-american fighting
against the government as opposed to
fighting on behalf of it and so what we
do here is begin focusing on the
backstory of the relationship between
Adam Beshear and the anti man by
establishing that the two were friends
at one point and that both served
together in Korea during the Cold War
with Adam Brashear picked up by the
Secret Service at the request of the
President on his way to the White House
he flashes back to his time during the
war at some point during his tour with
the US Marines enemy soldiers ambush
their platoon during the attack a man
named Conor was injured and Adam had
intervened saving his life in the
process and running off the enemy
soldiers now transitioning back to the
war room and President Kennedy the view
of Adam Brashear comes into play when
one of the generals refers to him as a
porch monkey now the racism that Bashir
has experienced over the course of his
life is further compounded on what is
revealed that during his time in Korea
he was subjected to the taunts of other
soldiers due to the color of his skin
now this in addition is compounded on
when we learned that during the early
1960s with the United States on the cusp
of social unrest as a result of the
civil rights movement in addition to the
racism that he has experienced from
white society black society has also
demonstrated a hatred towards him due to
the fact that he will not ally himself
with the civil rights movement and
instead desires to remain a bipartisan
hero protecting the world now what
happens next is extremely important and
effectively sets the stage for
everything that comes later on as the
president who did more for minorities
than any other president in history
Gravano incorporated this into the story
by having Kennedy provide an impassioned
speech in saying the society could have
easily dealt with the racial issue
sooner by introducing desegregation
eliminating Jim Crow laws but that this
was never done because the status quo
was acceptable to white society however
when a super-powered african-american
arrived on the scene with the power to
not only force the hand of social change
but do so with humanity having no way to
stop him the attitude of white society
shifted from acceptance of the status
quo to fear that the status quo could be
removed and there would be nothing they
could do about it
and so seeing a race war looming on the
horizon due to blue marbles continued
existence as a superhero on earth and
because the president serves at the
pleasure of the American people
Adam Brashear is called into the White
House for President Kennedy speaks with
him directly informing Beshear that his
presence as a hero means a potential
race war between those who want to keep
things as they are and those who want
change blue Marvel is asked to step down
from his role as a superhero and so
while the question from blue Marvel is
how long this is supposed to last the
indication from President Kennedy is
that after handing Adam Brashear the
Congressional Medal of Freedom that he's
being asked to step down from his life
as a superhero indefinitely
with that being said we're gonna bring
this video to an end I know it's a
cliffhanger but what we're gonna do is
we're gonna pick up with the second half
of this and we're gonna get into the
current events with Tony Stark search of
blue Marvel and how it is he's able to
bring him back and have him become a
member of the superhero community again
with that being said I will catch you
guys later peace
is so continuing our discussion on
Marvel's first black superhero following
anniversary stepping down from his role
as a blue marvel at the request of the
president rather than jumping back and
forth between the past and the current
events this section of the story instead
focuses largely on the present day
picking up with Tony Stark Reed Richards
and Hank Pym Kevin Grebo uses the
Avengers battle against anti man to
present a sense of urgency and that to
them they have never faced a being of
such power before with the century
counted as the strongest of their ranks
but being dispatched readily and with
minimal effort the questions remain as
to who the anti man is how he gained his
power and how to stop him furthermore as
Hank Pym mentions during the battle ante
man had referenced the blue Marvel and
while Reed had picked up on this as well
his only knowledge of Adam was that he
had acted as a superhero at some point
during the 1960's now this is
particularly important and the reason
why is that is arguably the smartest
person in the world a title the
fluctuates between himself and doom Reed
has access to some of the best
technology and a library of knowledge
but despite everything he knows the
concept of the blue Marvel is ambiguous
here and that to the best of Reed's
knowledge the blue Marvel had died
during a battle but he doesn't recall
any of his exploits now what this does
is established just how obscure the blue
Marvel is as well as the fact that he
had left the superhero scene long before
the dawn of the Fantastic Four
furthermore Reed also provides us with
some information on the power of an T
man and that according to his readings
the ante man had been getting weaker
towards the close of the fight and that
his dissipation was due to completely
running out of energy
furthermore Reed's analysis led him to
the conclusion that the anti man is
composed or powered by antimatter itself
while Tony Stark rejects this idea what
Kevin Grebo does is provide us with a
simplified version of the relationship
between normal matter and antimatter
according to read under normal
circumstances when antimatter and normal
matter combine the result is explosive
with both objects being completely
eliminated however because anti man is
powered by antimatter as opposed to
being made of it antimatter works more
like a battery that powers the ante man
who in turn uses his connection to
antimatter energy to achieve his
incredible strength invulnerability and
other powers
and so while reading him direct their
efforts to locating the source of
antimatter power Tony Stark spends his
time focusing on trying to bridge the
gap between the time blue marvel
disappeared and the current day at this
point Grove on thickens the plot of the
story and if I can be honest here for
the rest of the issue the events that
transpire will serve to demonstrate how
good of a writer grove o truly is with
tony stark standing as a director of
shield he currently has access to the
database of all intelligence
organization around the world however
during a search of the blue marvel the
only piece of information he can locate
comes through a single KGB file which
had previously been accessed and held by
the NSA however when he tries to access
the information we learned that the file
has been sealed and secured by executive
order something that could only be done
by the President of the United States
with the revelation that this file
contains something referred to as a blue
Marvel protocols once dark muses to
himself as to what the protocols are he
finds himself granted access to the
information contained within from here
we jump to Tony Stark meeting with
dum-dum Dugan to sidetrack for a second
Dugan was one of the original Howling
Commandos and served as Nick Fury
second-in-command during World War two
in addition to this when Nick Fury was
promoted to the position of executive
director of shield following its
creation during the early 1960s Dugan
had remained on board as one of Fury's
most trusted agents now the conversation
between the two tells us that during the
era of blue Marvel not only was shield
active but they were well aware of who
Adam Brashear was and what he had done
and his quest to protect the earth and
while stark questions Dugan regarding
what he knows about blue Marvel Duggan's
initial reaction is to tell Stark to
leave it alone
now I'll start believes that Dugan was
part of the cover-up the discussion
between the two is based on information
that we haven't received yet but putting
two and two together the situation seems
to have been that following blue Marvel
stepping down at the President's request
shield had been tasked with monitoring
Brashear for reasons unknown however
because shield existed outside the
authority of any existing government
during that time fury turned down the
request of the President to monitor
Brashear due to the fact that neither
Fury nor any of his group agreed with
the fact that Brashear had been
blackballed now when the question is
asked by stark as to why blue Marvel was
asked to step down in the first place
Dugan reiterates the same concerns
expressed by President Kennedy and that
because the United States was in the
midst of social turmoil regard
race relations the United States
government did not want to be stuck
behind the eight-ball with an extremely
powerful being working against them and
with no recourse of their own
furthermore as a conversation between
the two begins to wrap up the question
is asked that with all the power that
shield had including the power to
overrule any government in the world why
didn't they use that power to back blue
Marvel rather than letting the president
send him off now where Dubin refuses to
answer the question due to the fact that
he fears his words will be twisted and
he'll appear to be a racist the answer
to this question is that the purpose of
shield is to monitor threats to the
planet Earth not to involve itself in
the political entanglements of
individual countries and so because Tony
Stark is so persistent about discovering
what happened to blue Marvel and whether
or not he's still alive Dugan defers him
to a man named Kreutz the same general
that referred to blue Marvel as a porch
monkey in our first video and while
stark prepares to leave Dugan warns him
that traveling down this path may lead
stark to learning about things that he
won't like now transitioning to a place
called Church Falls Virginia a small
community just outside of Arlington we
learned that after the battle between
the Avengers and the anti man was
broadcast on television crews had come
to the conclusion that at some point
Stark would come looking for him in
search of blue Marvel now the
conversation that takes place between
the two is very important for a couple
of reasons the first is because Kreutz
will remove some of the mysteries
surrounding blue Marvel and what it was
it happened to him but also because
Grebo is going to use this exchange to
highlight how the world has changed and
the difference between how a majority of
society used to think regarding African
Americans and how they think now from
the perspective of Cruz the issue of
Adam Bashir was as much national as it
was global when world war ii had ended
in europe was being carved up by both
the United States and the Soviet Union
the Cold War came into fruition as the
two nations attempted to expand their
spheres of influence regarding
capitalism and communism as a result
while the second Red Scare only lasted
between 1947 and 1957 the concern of
communist ideology spreading to the
United States was still very real this
combined with the belief that Adam
Brashear could have been another
extremist like Malcolm X or an
insurrectionist like Gabriel Prosser a
man who led a slave rebellion in the
summer of 1871 to a corner believing
that Breshears actions could have
brought ruin to the entire country had
he turned against
United States this sentiment was
compounded on by men like Bolivar Trask
who used the efforts of blue Marvel to
further their own anti-mutant agenda by
arguing that even if rich Shearer was
not a mutant while he existed prior to
the formation of the x-men he was an
indication that super-powered people
were emerging because a government would
be unable to control them if
super-powered people were to band
together they could top of the world's
governments and if they descend into
civil war they could destabilize the
world's socio-economic environments as a
result in addition to blue Marvel being
asked to step down by Kennedy his
actions led to the federal government
launching project wide-awake a joint
effort by the Defense Department the CIA
the National Security Council all headed
by Henry Peter Gyrich which would go on
to see the creation and implementation
of sentinels and so in order to end the
legacy of blue Marvel before being asked
to step down by President Kennedy he had
called blue Marvel n for final mission
which had been classified above
top-secret at some point the US
government's early warning system had
detected an alien presence heading
toward the planet earth calling Brashear
in to deal with the alien the primary
goal was to assess and neutralize the
threat but the secondary goal was to put
for sure in a situation where he may
have been killed in action with Russia R
and the alien engaging in battle we
learned that from the information
gathered by shield intelligence the
alien was a scout for an invading Armada
looking to either conquer or destroy the
earth while the situation seemed evenly
matched with Brashear on the ropes and
possibly being killed by the alien
during the battle he was able to muster
his power together and in turn destroy
the alien and so his crews concludes his
story by telling Stark de this was the
last time he had ever seen Brashear
Starks response is that Brashear was the
only person who had knowledge on who an
T man was and how to defeat him but
rather than being able to speak with
bashir and learn what he knew about an
team and the government sent him on a
suicide mission in an effort to maintain
control of the United States however
what curve au does here is drop a
massive bomb by having Kreutz inform
Stark that blue Marvel's death was a
ruse in order to ensure that he wouldn't
become a martyr by those who look to
capitalize on his legacy for their own
ends the meeting between President
Kennedy and blue Marvel was organized in
secret with all other branches of the
intelligence agencies being led to
believe that blue Marvel had died
fighting the alien and protecting the
earth as well as providing a set of blue
Marvel protocols that were incomplete
handing Tony Stark a complete
protocols which contains all information
on Adam Brashear we pick up in Maryland
with a woman named Candace Brashear
revealing that Adam is still alive Tony
Stark asked Candace if her husband is
available but because it's Thursday
Candace informed stark that her husband
is a teacher and has a late class
becoming frustrated over the fact that
Stark is being ambiguous as to why
they're pursuing Adam Tony calls Candace
by another name miss Frazier while we're
not initially told what the significance
of this is the reaction of Candace
indicates that her current identity is a
false one something that's confirmed
when stark reveals that Candace's real
name is Marlene Frazier and establishes
that she's an agent of the federal
government informing her that he's read
the complete blue Marvel protocols and
is aware that Adam Brashear is alive but
does not know where he's located as the
story comes to a close the events
transition to the physics department of
the University of Maryland as Adam
concludes his class assigning a chapter
on the Heisenberg uncertainty principle
a concept of quantum mechanics that
deals with the contradiction of
trajectory of matter and observation
Adam receives a call from his wife
Candace advising him that shield is
looking for him with that being said
we're gonna bring this video to an end I
don't know about you guys but I love
this story so far and I will catch you
guys later peace so getting into part
three of our discussion on Adam Brashear
the story actually shifts its focus away
from Tony Stark's search for blue Marvel
and focuses on Adams life after he was
asked to step down by President Kennedy
picking up with a man named general
Mason who as far as I know exists only
within the context of this story the
indication seems to be that in addition
to asking blue Marvel to step down
President Kennedy authorized the United
States military to keep an eye on blue
Marvel to ensure that he did not become
a credible threat to the United States
now the reason why the United States
military was chosen to do this is that
if you recall our last video we had
talked about how shield was given the
opportunity but ultimately turned it
down due to the fact that neither Nick
Fury nor any of his subordinates agreed
with what had been done to blue Marvel
now something that's really interesting
here is that Grebo does not depict the
situation as the US military against
blue Marvel instead he provides us with
a real-world scenario in that while
those in the middle
we are required to follow the orders
handed down to them not everyone agrees
with what's going on as some of the
soldiers state if the government is
concerned about blue Marvel it would
make more sense and be more appropriate
to simply ask him to work for the
government especially considering the
fact that he's done so much to protect
the world bringing in a woman named
Marlene Frasier at the time of her first
meeting with military intelligence she's
established as being relatively neutral
with regards to blue Marvel himself now
this is something done intentionally by
Kevin Grebo and will actually find out
why later in this series but the
superior of Marlene is against the idea
of sending her on her mission now in
terms of his depiction a Grove Oh
actually leaves it to us to decide if
this man is racist or not and that he
states that the culture of
african-americans is different from that
of whites while this is a true statement
the context of the situation is
ambiguous and that this man is not
talking among his friends and nothing
he's saying is explicitly racist in and
of itself but the result of the meeting
is that Marlene is being tasked with
engaging in a relationship with blue
Marvel for the purpose of monitoring him
now at this point we jump to the current
day with Marlene's entire story being
provided to blue Marvel firsthand now
the reaction of blue Marvel during the
conversation is exactly what we would
expect and that he's basically learning
that the entire marriage between himself
and Marlene was rooted in deception from
the perspective of Adam he was more like
a personal project for Marlene rather
than an actual love interest something
that's compounded on when she reveals
that she had spent all of her time
reading up on everything about Adam
prior to meeting him for the first time
where Marlene pleads her case and saying
that at the time she was operating in
the interests of her country for Adam
all of this is irrelevant the reason why
is that in addition to learning that his
marriage is a lie after everything he
had done for the United States and in
the world in the end the government
still didn't trust him however for
Marlene while her original intention was
to prove her worth as a spy as time
progressed she developed an actual love
towards Adam while some of this was due
to the time they spent together it was
also due to the experiences the two of
them shared as they encountered racism
and public society and so what Grebo is
basically doing here is using the
character of Marlene to reflect the part
of society who were raised isolated from
such intense racism and had no idea of
how rooted it was
in the rest of the United States because
Adam consistently took the high road
despite the fact that he could have
obliterated any of the races individuals
he had encountered Marlins affections
grew in at to her eyes
Adam was everything a man should be and
that he was honorable intelligent and
compassionate and so as time passed
contact was eventually severed between
herself and her superior allowing her to
give herself completely to Adam and cast
aside her mission but for Adam all of
the information revealed here is more
than he can bear and now the personal
struggles he endure required that he
walk away from being a hero for Earth
but that despite it all the one person
that he could rely on was his wife but
after the revelation of her role in his
life despite the affection she claimed
to have developed over the years in the
end Adam feels as isolated and alone as
he did when he left the White House
after being asked to step down and so
faced with the facts Adam makes a
decision to leave his wife due to her
deception and so picking up on the blue
area of the moon this story shifts his
focus to the relationship between blue
Marvel and The Watcher not for me this
is probably one of the best moments of
the story and that this discussion
allows for an outpouring of blue Marvel
himself with The Watcher arriving his
experiences monitoring the multiverse
and all occupants within have provided
him with valuable insight into the
nature of people as such his argument
here is that Marlene is only human and
makes mistakes just like everyone else
furthermore blue Marvel is talking out
of anger here in that to him he can find
it everything in Marlene but because The
Watcher sees and knows all blue Marvel's
claim has a fault as The Watcher forces
him to admit Adam only revealed to
Marlene what she needed to know and so
in truth his actions are really no
different than hers and so following
this between their discussion the
problem blue Marvel faces is that on one
hand he has to deal with the fact that
he has to return to his position as a
hero in order to safeguard against the
anti man but on the other hand all he is
known from society is mistrust and
deceit ranging from society itself to
his wife and so transitioning to the
shield Helicarrier above New York the
conversation between Reed Richards and
Tony Stark reveals that the anti man has
returned furthermore the atmosphere is
beginning to grow with antimatter energy
meaning that an T man is growing
stronger by feeding on its power and so
as the story begins
come to a close Tony Stark is greeted by
the arrival of Adam Brashear who sought
out Tony Stark and we received there's a
way for him to help bring an end to the
actions of anti man
with that being said we're gonna bring
this video to an end and I will catch
you guys later
post
so continuing our discussion on blue
Marvel we pick back up with Adam
Brashear during his first encounter with
Tony Stark Reed Richards and Hank Pym
but we also get a little more insight
into the history of his character and
the answer to the question of how he
gained his powers
so the story initially opens with Adam
Brashear in amphibious Naval Base little
Creek in North Carolina now something
I'd like to point out here is that in
real life
this Naval Base is actually in Norfolk
Virginia and deals with offensive naval
operations and deploying soldiers
overseas and into hostile shores but the
basis behind Griffo bringing us as part
of the story is to focus on the history
of Adam Brashear and Connor Sims the
ante man what we learn here is that
contrary to previous depictions of white
Americans in the story up to this point
not everyone was racist during Adams
time prior to becoming the blue marvel
in this instance Adam was dealing with
some racist members of the Navy and
where previously he had remained
hands-off rather than facing
dishonorable discharge for conduct
unbecoming of an officer by way of
fighting he along with Connor Sims
finally fought back and gave the
soldiers a lesson in humility now
transitioning to the present day we join
Adam Brashear alongside Tony Stark Reed
Richards and Hank Pym aboard the shield
Helicarrier above New York something I'd
like to mention here is that where I'm
normally straightforward on what I like
and dislike about a section of a story
and comics in this instance I'm actually
on the fence here the reason why is that
with Adam Brashear arriving on board the
Helicarrier start extends an olive
branch of friendship to Brashear by
offering a formal apology on behalf of
the United States and the President
himself would like to formally welcome
blue Marvel back to the superhero
landscape however Brashear doesn't
really want to hear it and where he
states that his intention is to focus on
the here and now by providing the group
with his knowledge of an team and to be
quite frank I don't think this was the
right road to take you know this is
something that we'll get further into
here in a second but at the moment the
conversation shifts his focus to an T
man himself according to read the issue
that they face is that an T man is
wildly powerful more so than any one of
the Avengers have ever faced before now
to be clear this does not mean that the
anti man is the most powerful being in
existence cosmic entities like Galactus
and others are still far beyond anything
that an T man is capable of it's simply
that within the context of earth-based
villains none of the Avengers have
fought anyone like this before
something else that Grebo does here is
provide us with an understanding of just
how intelligent Adam Beshear is and
saying that he knows his way around a
science lab but that he also knows the
exact method in terms of how auntie
man's powers work and the reason for
this comes in the form of brashears
backstory
what we're told is that at some point
during the careers of himself an auntie
man Connor Simms had become part of Army
Intelligence
while Beshear worked on a project
involving harnessing the power of
antimatter as a source of energy where
the military had intended to weaponize
this power before it was released to the
general public for other applications at
some point and for reasons unknown the
experiment went awry bathing both Adam
Brashear and counter Sims and antimatter
energy where Sims was able to pull
Mercer from the wreckage Sims appeared
to have succumbed to the energy and was
completely obliterated
as a result Connor Sims became the anti
man clubber sure became the blue marvel
now what curve I was doing here is
providing us with the basis behind blue
marvel's power but to be honest he
doesn't really do the best job
explaining exactly what Bashir is
capable of and clear and simple terms
having said that the best way to think
of blue Marvel is that he is a less
powerful version of Franklin Richards
where Franklin can manipulate all matter
in existence regardless of whether it be
normal matter or antimatter Anna
Brashear is powered by and can only
manipulate antimatter what this means is
that if for sure were to enter the
negative zone he would be godlike in
terms of his ability to manipulate and
control all things within that space but
within the normal universe he's capable
of incredible strength speed and
durability but also has enhanced senses
and like at the same time the ante man
is the same way but the best way I can
explain his powers would be to say that
he is an incomplete version of blue
Marvel Antibes an has all the same
abilities as Brashear but his control
over them is known as acute and his
molecular structure is literally
unstable now back to the conversation at
hand regarding Brashear Stark Reed and
Pym Hanks initial question is that if
Russia was watching the world unfold
following the assassinations of Kennedy
and Martin Luther King jr. he had to
notice that the world was improving what
him is basically saying here is that
Brashear could have come back at any
point in time and despite what he might
say about having his choices limited at
the end of the day at least some part of
his isolation was voluntary however
according to Bashir his view is that the
President of the United States had
requested that he stepped down and that
in his mind defying every question the
President on that level would break the
law
as the one thing that holds society
together and keeps anarchy from reigning
supreme and the eyes are Brashear
maintaining the law is of the utmost
importance now returning to our
discussion on the attempt at Stark to
apologize for his past actions of the
United States and its rejection by
Brashear where Adam leaves to take care
of personal matters
this concept is discussed further by
Reid Tony and PEM where Hank doesn't
seem to grasp why it is that Brashear
takes the attitude that he does
Bravo establishes Reid as the voice of
reason and does this by using the idea
of mutants as an example of how
prejudice still exists within the realm
of Marvel Comics what Reid tells us is
that were the Avengers or the Fantastic
Four operate to save the world
whenever there was successful and
quelling a threat there lauded as heroes
but when the x-men performed the same
act they're shunned by humanity - Reid
prior to the birth of Franklin followed
by valaria he had never had any reason
to pay any attention to the affairs of
mutants and the issues that they faced
in society
however because both his children are
mutants with incredible powers by way of
Franklin's ability to warp reality and
Valerius genius-level intellect the
issues faced by mutants came into full
swing and so what Griffo is doing here
is making an analogy by comparing the
position of Reid before and after the
birth of his children to the position of
America following the advent of
nationwide media what I mean here is
that during the time of regional news
the racial issues in the United States
were only really known by intelligence
organizations under the government and
individuals residing in the areas whose
issues were most prevalent however
following the advent of nationwide news
families on one side of the country
could see what was happening on the
other side and as a result the totality
of racism in the United States was
thrown into view for the world to see
leading to a massive upheaval regarding
how American citizens viewed the nation
as a whole now picking back up with
bashir we transitioned to his underwater
fortress and the Mariana Trench within
the Atlantic Ocean as the largest cavern
in the world and deep enough to house
Mount Everest with room to spare the
trench was a perfect location for blue
Marvel's base of operations and that the
only person who would have been able to
access it would have been named the
Submariner in greeting his old friend
this particular moment is very important
for several reasons the firs is that it
goes towards establishing how long
Bashir had operated as a superhero and
that name woo had predated
but the two of them were extremely close
friends the second is that because the
two were friends this establishes that
in the eyes of name were Brashear was an
honorable man which is something really
found and that name are pretty much
hates everyone else what we're also told
is that regarding his physical strength
Brashear is on par with both Thor and
The Incredible Hulk sowing that stated
by name or in that when he and Bashir
had first met that she had fought one
another Doosan Amer's belief that were
she was simply invading his oceans the
final reason why the encounter between
the two is so important is due to the
fact that name were actually s wages
were sheer from abandoning the Avengers
and leaving them to their own devices
and intimidate the anti man we're
Beshear voices his irritation over the
nature of politics and that he was
previously asked to step down but is now
being asked to come back even after
learning that he spent his whole life
being monitored Namor uses his
experience fighting among the invaders
to provide a measure of perspective what
Namor says here is that when he fought
alongside Captain America Bucky Barnes
and Jim Hammond during World War two he
was also fighting alongside what were
referred to as Red Tails now the Red
Tails was a nickname for pilots who
painted the tails of their planes red
but the official name for this group was
a Tuskegee Airman as african-americans
fighting during World War two the
Tuskegee Airmen were a real world
element in society but because African
Americans were looked down upon during
this time the Tuskegee Airmen were
considered unintelligent and largely
treated as cannon fodder however in the
eyes of name war they were the true
embodiment of bravery and that through
it all they never turned their backs on
a fight were always the first ones in
and the last ones out using this as a
platform
nemr makes the case that regardless of
the conflict faced by any one man
there's always a choice to be made
regarding whether or not to act and
there will always be evil in the world
as a result those with the power to
confront that evil have a responsibility
to do so
even if it flies in the face of
everything that they believe and this
logic is based solely on the idea that
should they not act the evil of
individuals in the world would reign
supreme and so taking the words of name
word a heart Brashear Dawn's as blue
marvel uniform with the intention of
returning to read start and pen and Ally
himself in their efforts to defeat the
anti man however before he can achieve
this counter makes his return to
confront Adam for the first time since
her last encounter
in the 1960s now what Garbo does here is
provide us with the final piece of the
back story between Simms and Brashear
what we learn here is that following the
experiment they gave them their powers
Sims had somehow we materialized after
which he'd been taken to Breshears
underwater facility where Sims initially
greeted Brashear as a friend Sims was
informed that he had been in a coma for
a month furthermore after analyzing his
molecular structure Brashear came to the
conclusion that Sims molecules were
essentially breaking down in the atomic
level meaning that he appeared to be
dying
however for Sims the end of his
existence as a normal human and rebirth
through the power of antimatter made him
mentally unstable and to his insanity he
had come to the conclusion that
society's racism and Prejudice needed to
be eliminated to make way for utopia of
sorts even if it required the
destruction of all life at the same time
where Bashir tries to reason with Sims
and recalling some of the get-togethers
that their families had shared with the
two becoming godfather to the others
children in the end Sims came to the
belief that Brashear had stolen his
family away from him however atom
counters this by stating that the
instability of Sims put not just society
but his own family in danger as such
pressure hit Sims family away under the
belief that he could reason with Sims
and restore him to normalcy furthermore
Brashear tries to help Sims understand
that the world isn't the way that it
used to be and while there will always
be prejudice in the world as his human
nature the landscape of open racism is
no longer an issue and that people are
more acceptable than they were before
but despite all of this reasoning in the
end Sims believes that brashears
willingness to give society a chance to
demonstrate the steps is taken towards
acceptance is an inherent weakness and
that if Brashear has truly allied
himself with humanity that he's just as
guilty as everyone else and so as this
issue comes to a close
Sims attached for sure knocking him
unconscious in the process and uses the
opportunity to continue his campaign
against humanity and his goal of
eliminating all life on the planet Earth
with that being said we're gonna bring
this video to an end and let me know
what you guys think about this issue so
far and I will catch you guys later
peace
so what I want to do here is have a
discussion about the various cosmic
entities of the all-new all-different
mobile prime universe starting with
colitis now what I'm hoping is that at
the end of all this you'll have a strong
understanding of his character relative
to the number of issues that we have as
well as how his involvement in the new
universe actually helps us to understand
how things relate to the pre secret wars
universe
so the all-new all-different Galactus
comes to us as part of Al Ewing's
all-new all-different Ultimates and
while I will have a video on that team
as part of a lead-up to civil war to
what Al Ewing does here is actually
really interesting to sidetrack for a
second when Galactus first debuted in
the original Marvel Universe
well he wasn't provided an origin in his
first few appearances the explanation of
his existence came by way of Thor vol 1
issues 168 through 170 originally
established as being a universal
Explorer named Galan in the Earth's zero
continuity at the end of that universes
life Galactus remained the sole survivor
merging with that reality's version of
eternity during this birthing process
Galactus had fashioned a vessel for
himself allowing an incubation period of
several million years where he gathered
his energies constructed a suit to
contain those energies and emerged as a
Galactus that we all know and love
consuming planets to sustain his life
now all the reasons for Galactus being a
cosmic necessity have changed over the
years ranging from a meta commentary on
his representation of life death and
rebirth as well as a physical force
whose death Unleashed Abraxas who
threatened the multiverse on the whole a
Ewing does not actually provide us with
an expansive origin and the Marvel prime
universe while there are different
explanations that could be offered for
this and truth I would surmise that with
Galactus being such a well-known
character even if his origin is only
slightly understood by casual readers
it's still understood and so the
information provided actually just gives
us a one-page synopsis sticking with a
classic story of Galactus hailing from
the earth zero continuity and that said
because the Ultimates exist to in threat
to the universe but to also boost an
anticipation for the start of the series
the first being encountered by The
Ultimates came in the form of Galactus
taking place in issues number one and
number two in November in December of
2015 as the official launch title and a
self-contained story what we're told
is that from the perspective of blue
Marvel and Black Panther Galactus is
hunger is not a requirement for him
instead this is a byproduct of the
incubation period meaning this process
could be reversed now somebody take note
of here is that al Ewing is taking
certain liberties and that as far as I'm
aware the hunger of Galactus is an
intrinsic part of his character and no
one had ever created a story where his
hunger was depicted as something that
could be cured the only exception to
this that I can think of came in the
first six issues of the 2003 Thanos solo
series by jim Starlin which depicted
Galactus as hunger as a multiversal
entity working through Galactus and
attempting to consume realities however
because this story arch stretched the
limits of credulity even by comic
standards fans don't generally consider
it to be canon or in existence now in
terms of The Ultimates after putting
their efforts together the black panther
and blue Marvel reasoned that if
Galactus is hunger emerged following his
time in the incubation chamber the
hunger could be reversed by forcing
Galactus back into the chamber to this
end the Ultimates backtrack Galactus his
time as a devourer of worlds eventually
arriving at our key Opia the first
planet Galactus it consumed after
emerging scavenging the dead world and
reconstructing the incubation chamber
the entirety of the Ultimates including
Carol Danvers Monica Rambeau
America Chavez and black panther
combined their powers in an effort to
force Galactus back into his chamber
emerging as a life bringer at the
conclusion of issue number two valuing
established that instead of consuming
worlds and ending life Galactus now
functions as the source of life creating
in healing worlds he had previously
consumed beginning with our key obeah
following this and going into the next
five titles leading up to issue number
seven as the most current release the
ultimate slime served to provide two
plots the first following the Ultimates
themselves and leading into civil war
two for the second following Galactus
and an explanation of the all-new
all-different model prime universe
picking up an issue number four
following the Ultimates attempts to
understand the space-time continuum in
the post secret wars continuity the
lackeys himself was contacted by
eternity who advised of the ultimate
actions and that they could not proceed
visiting the team amidst their journey
into the previous realm of the beyonders
which now exists as a void of
nothingness valuing begins the first
steps of referencing the pre secret wars
universe
where carol danvers offers the
explanation that the team sought to
understand the space-time continuum
Galactus provides her with a glimpse of
how he sees time establishing that were
model had never officially provided an
answer the fact remains that secret Wars
was not a reboot
instead the events that took place in
the earth-616 universe still happened
but secret Wars
allow for reshuffling of characters in
realities this comes with the fact that
as Galactus shows us the death of the
original Captain Marvel the iron man
armor wars and the onslaught saga our
memories that he still maintains at the
same time he also makes reference to
Marvel slamming time scale and the idea
of retcons
to sidetrack with marvel's publications
it was standard practice for them to
include dates and references to
presidents throughout the 1960s and
1970s but with the 1980 seeing their
final reference to a concrete period in
the real world from that point going
forward all absolute dates of reference
were eliminated what this meant was that
instead of saying Civil War happened in
a certain year and during a certain
month instead the event would take place
with future stories referencing it as a
year or three years ago as a result
between 1984 and the current day
everything within Marvel Comics is
assumed to have taken place within a
10-year window in addition to this
Galactus states that the past is never
concrete and then it can always be
changed now this is really more of a
meta commentary on retroactive
continuities and the idea that various
writers will alter the history of models
past in order to suit an existing story
or to introduce a character as an
example within the Marvel Universe
itself
blue Marvel did not exist until 2009
when Kevin Bravo had created him and
altered the history of Marvel to
establish that Adam Brashear was
Marvel's first black superhero now while
I do have a video explaining these
concepts in more detail for those who
still find them a little confusing with
Galactus forcing the heroes to sleep and
returning them to the main universe he's
called before eternity who reveals that
he's being kept in Chains and was placed
in this position by an unknown being now
something actually want to do here is I
want to step away from this for a minute
and I want to have a discussion on the
role of eternity in the new Marvel prime
universe within the old universe
eternity existed as a singular being and
a physical manifestation of each
universe that existed however because
had creative battleworld during secret
Wars while the planet was composed of
different realities instead of
battleworld having a version of eternity
for each territory the whole of battle
world combined to allow for singular
entity who was kept under the control of
dooms power now this is particularly
important due to the fact that the fan
community was largely split over the
idea of a multiversal version of
eternity existing under the Living
Tribunal and serving to represent the
multiverse itself holding it all
together while the idea of a multiverse
eternity was alluded to but never really
confirmed prior to and during Secret
Wars with Al Ewing's Ultimates his
information reveals that after the
destruction of battle world and the
creation of the multiverse by Owen Reese
Franklin Richards and Reed Richards a
multi virtual eternity came into
existence holding the multiverse
together under the New Living Tribunal
and spawning the cosmic entities and so
with a multiverse itself in Chains
Galactus was tasked with discovering who
it was it did this and how to restore
things to normal
picking up with issue number six where
Galactus continues his quest as it was
assigned by eternity during his travels
he encounters master order and Lord
chaos as the representations of order
and chaos who work against one another
and maintain universal balance through
their conflict because Galactus had
previously been known as the world
devour to the mind of Lord chaos
Galactus represented destruction and
catastrophe but for master order the
destruction of Galactus was part of the
cosmic order allowing for the death of
planets and the balance of the universal
population and but because he has
vacated that role and stepped into the
position of the life bringer the Lord
chaos is no longer satisfied due to
Galactus failing to inflict destruction
the master order is unsatisfied due to
Galactus stepping away from the status
quo to this end the entities transported
Galactus to the SuperFlow which existed
as a space between realities with the
intention of forcing Galactus back into
his position and however because master
order and Lord chaos exists in such
rigid forms with Galactus maintaining
free will the two entities are
completely overpowered and forced to
retrieve after which Galactus is brought
before Owen Reese the molecule man now
for this bit of the discussion what we
have previously engaged in a bit of meta
commentary the conversation between
Galactus and Owen Reese is extremely
important due to the
that molecule man will actually address
the reader based directly and the
community's view of the all-new
all-different universe what molecule man
gets extremely wordy and goes as far as
to use a modified version of the
Schrodinger's cat thought experiment the
long and short of this is that molecule
man addresses the issue of model
existing in a state of flux to sidetrack
here the thought experiment of
Schrodinger's cat is a concept in
quantum mechanics offering the idea that
if an unobserved action occurs any and
all possibilities of that action are
available however once that observation
occurs an absolute answer is provided
and the question is definitively
answered while this may seem a little
confusing to simplify things molecule
man is saying that the problem with the
current universe is that it was rebooted
but it wasn't rebooted furthermore there
are some beings within the universe who
do not remember the events of the
multiverse or collapse and Sucher wars
but there are also some who do as a
result there are those who believed that
the multiverse did collapse and was
recreated but there are also those that
don't and what al Ewing is doing here is
offering a statement to us and Marvel
saying that you can't have it both ways
you can't shuffle some characters around
introduce new teams and offer
conflicting memories all while calling
it a reboot if you haven't actually
rebooted anything either it's a reboot
or it's not what I want to do here is I
want to talk about The Ultimates more
specifically this second storyline
basically focuses on two aspects it
focuses on the return of Thanos and it
focuses on Galactus creating a new
Herald and so I'm still not sure which
one of those titles I'm gonna pick but
the idea here is that for those of you
guys who don't know with Marvel Comics
The Ultimates are like this this
multiversal group they're like the
avengers on a much grander scale now The
Ultimates don't exist in the multiverse
it's not like you know the members hail
from different universes and the Marvel
multiverse they all hail from the
earth-616 universe but the idea behind
this is to have them face threats from
across the multiverse that threatened
the main Marvel earth-616 reality the
issue with this is that there is much a
defensive measure as they are an
exploratory team and so the goal here is
to to basically face off against threats
that most people can't deal with that's
one of the reasons why we have such
powerhouse characters that's why we have
Carol Danvers that's why we have the
intelligence of Black Panther as
we have Adam Brashear we have spectrum
we have America Chavez we have some
really really powerful beings here and
the idea is that again they're designed
to step up against multiversal threats
now we had talked in my video about the
all-new all-different Galactus that
their first task was to basically
eliminate the hunger of Galactus due to
the fact that by clutches traveling
around the universe and consuming worlds
that he and of himself was destructive
the issue with this is that a Ewing I
imagine would have in some form or
fashion whether he knew about it through
a retcon or whether he somebody just
didn't know about it or didn't care it
begs the question how do those
Celestials fit into this because those
are guys who don't know in Marvel Comics
Celestials quite literally plant eggs in
worlds and they will emerge after some
million years or however long it is but
Galactus running around and consuming
worlds is just as much a safeguard for
the universe as it is for him consuming
his own hunger because if he wasn't
consuming worlds then it would result in
these in Celestials running rampant
throughout the cosmos so the idea is to
basically keep things from going insane
and having said that because this second
volume is part of the civil war to event
the one of the interesting things about
this is that the tie-ins they're a
little lackluster but it's also a good
way that Marvel has done it instead of
tying them directly into Civil War to
you which would mean know that we will
basically have to hold off all the
volumes until Civil War 2 comes out
instead they basically just reference
the events of Civil War 2 but things are
still going on in their individual
stories and so in truth the Civil War to
tie ends are really standalone stories
you don't really have to read the main
Civil War 2 story in order to read the
the second volume of all these different
publications x-23 and Avengers and so on
and so forth it can't hurt you know to
read civil war 2 as it goes on but it's
not a requirement and so what Ultimates
what the second issue does or I guess
the second run does is it initially
picks up with a character called the
infinite now we don't really know
anything about this guy but what a Ewing
does is he initially jumps back to 1998
with Adam Brashear working alongside as
his son Kevin now Adam for sure of
course we know is a genius-level
scientist his intelligence isn't
necessarily up there with black panther
but he's not that far off and so his son
Kevin had very much followed his
footsteps in terms of pursuing you know
these paths of science and the result
was that it seemed to be these these
incursions or these mini a temporal way
that resulted in some being trying to
enter the Marvel earth-616 continuity
and so because this has been going on
for decades
Adam Brashear alongside of son had been
working to try to prevent this from
happening now the other half of this
though is that Ed embrasure son Kevin
had at one point vanished which is one
of the reasons why we hadn't seen him
for so long
during the early issues of his run in
Marvel Comics with Mighty Avengers and
so on and so forth he was eventually
brought back but he wasn't he didn't
quite operate in the same capacity that
he did in this but again this is really
just a Ewing setting things up but
because of the fact that this highs into
Civil War to the main event itself
focuses on a character named Ulysses who
is an inhuman with the ability to
predict the future now as we discussed
in my Steve Rogers Captain America video
these predictions are not 100% accurate
but they're close enough that Carol
Danvers is willing to gamble on the
accuracy of these in order to basically
stop crimes before they happen or to
stop incidents before they happen now
because of the arrival of Ulysses it's
to turn the tables on how it is an atom
brashear have used these temporal risks
with regards to this info not trying to
come through but previously it seemed
like it was a threat instead Anna
Brashear begins to look at it as the
very basis behind the Ultimates Charter
in the sense that they're exploratory
they're investigators their problem
solvers and so we're the initial idea
here is that this machine is being
developed with a combination of The
Ultimates team as a whole in order to
stop this danger Adam Brashear realizes
that it's actually to figure things out
and so what happens is that when this
rift opens up they basically reach out
to this humanoid being to the infinite
and they bring him in and Adam Brashear
states to everybody that the case with
this is that he's basically just a
scientist is a scientist from another
universe that was exploring the
multiverse and the Ultimates can learn
just as much from infinite as infinite
can learn from them and so because this
is really not a danger but it falls in
line with the ideology of The Ultimates
in terms of looking at problems and
trying to get them figured out finding
solutions as over here we jump to Connor
Sims now for those of you guys who have
seen my video on atom brashears
character with his first appearance as
it was written by Kevin Griffo the
experiment that gave Adam Brashear his
powers also gave Connor Simpsons powers
the difference here is that for all
intents and purposes when it comes to
just sheer raw power
Connor Sims is pretty far beyond Adam
Brashear Connor Sims has the ability to
manipulate antimatter which is the
opposite of normal matter but it still
allows him the ability to manipulate
on a subatomic scale and so he's
basically a character who can warp
reality the issue with this is that
counter sims was eventually what or at
least was initially believed to have
been destroyed during atom brashears
first encounter I guess the the story
that final encounter with him but it
wasn't until a Ewing came back and wrote
The Ultimates that he revealed the
Connor Sims was alive he was just out in
space somewhere and no one knew about it
but Connor Sims himself didn't really
know what was going on
now the reason seemed to be based on the
idea of seeker wars when Reed Richards
had restored the multiverse that Connor
Sims memories were wiped but then we
learned that Connor Sims did remember
everything he remembered all the things
that he had done but he had also come to
a realization and the realization he had
come to was that eternity had been
chained that some cosmic force out there
which seems to be more powerful than
eternity had chained all of reality or
chained the universe itself and the idea
of Connor symbols that it had driven him
insane by knowing this or at least not
traditionally insane but in a driven to
the brink of madness in the sense that
his mind couldn't quite grasp it because
he had come to the realization there's a
being out there of such incredible power
and it's not a being that's kind it's a
being that is dangerous it's a being
that seems to be evil and so because
Connor Sims doesn't see the world the
same way people do the thing that we
normally do because he sees the world
and atomic particles and he sees the
world in terms of its molecular
structure and in matter and energy and
so on and so forth he basically came to
the realization that there's like a
giant barrier around the universe that
they can't get out of and so someone is
basically turned the Marvel earth-616
universe into a giant prison and he's
trying to figure out a way to get out
but he's also overwhelmed by this and so
what happens is that while he is you
know being held a confinement of his own
free will due to the fact that he's
afraid of his power sort of just
breaking loose in an unbridled fashion
he's immediately met by the arrival of
Thanos now the other half of this is
that in the events leading up to civil
war to Thanos had attacked the planet
earth in pursuit of the Cosmic Cube that
had been created by shield which is what
led to Avengers standoff and the
recreation of Steve Rogers past again we
have that in my video on on Captain
America Steve Rogers but Thanos had been
captured by a combination of the
Avengers and The Ultimates and had been
held prisoner under the Ultimates base
of operations which is called the
Triskelion and so because of this when
Connor Sims had arrived
and Thanos had come to the realization
of just how powerful Connor Sims is he
began to devise a plan to basically
manipulate Connor Sims and not only
freeing him but then turning Connor Sims
into a puppet for his own goals and so
while Connor Sims is dealing with his
own you know emotions and the
overwhelming nature of what's happening
with things
Santos appears to him and begins
manipulating him now this is when all
Ewing starts to incorporate a lot of
things in terms of what's going on with
Thanos right now because all we really
had with his reimburses was that he was
just there he was looking for a cosmic
cube he was defeated he had killed James
Rhodes he had injured she-hulk and then
he was taken prisoner and that was it we
didn't really have anything to go on
here we knew that because of the fact
that mistress death had barred him from
the realm of death it basically made him
effectively immortal that when the
restoration of the multiverse happened
by Reed Richards at the end of Secret
Wars that he was just thrown outside of
all reality he was thrown into the realm
of nothingness basically and that's when
he re-emerged though we didn't really
know anything else besides that and so
what this did is this turned into a
question of what happens next what
happens with Thanos now and this is what
we get
Thanos basically says that over the
course of his life he had fallen in love
with mistress death that was that was
his big claim to fame
that was his huge staple before Secret
Wars it was his pursuit of the
affections of mistress death it's why he
gained the Infinity Gauntlet and wiped
out half the life in the universe it's
why he pursued the Cosmic Cube is what
he did all these things because he
wanted the affections of mistress death
the other half of this was that when he
was outside of the multiverse he
basically fell in love with a what it
seems to be an entity called nothingness
now we know virtually nothing about this
I mean we don't know if nothingness is
even an entity or if it's just the idea
that Thanos has just fallen to the point
where he's just in love with the idea of
destroying all things in existence we
have no idea what direction Al Ewing is
going with this but basically Ewing has
taken Thanos and removed him from his
love with mistress death and so while
this is going on all these goading
Connor Sims we end up finding that the
ultimate in and of themselves are
fighting one another and the reason why
is because with Ulysses predicting that
a briefcase the contents of a briefcase
was going to lead to a massive amount of
destruction that Carol Danvers had
organized the Ultimates and pursuing a
woman named Allison Green now this is
basically a lying or at least it seems
to be a you ain't
telling us the Connor Sims is not always
right and the reason why is because
while there's some disagreement while
the soldiers of Carol Danvers are a
little more harsh than they need to be
and it creates a little bit of rivalry
between the Ultimates themselves when
they get the briefcase back and they
open it up they realize there's nothing
there and this just creates a huge
amount of backlash in the team it really
leads to like the destruction of the
team in traditional means because of the
fact that no one agrees Carol Danvers
says hey look like we're trying to stop
crimes yes they haven't done anything
now but a guy who says he could see the
future and he's been accurate so far so
it means that if he says they're going
to do something then they're likely
going to now what's interesting about
this and this is one of the reasons why
like a lot of fans at the moment hate
Carol Danvers because in the face of a
briefcase that's empty in the face of
the fact that Ulysses was wrong she
refuses to accept that she simply just
says no no he's right it's it's just you
know he was talking about a different
briefcases all it was he was talking
about something else but he's been right
90% of the time and so even if he's
wrong 10% of the time it's better to
lock up innocent people than to let
guilty people go free and that's
basically what she's saying here that's
the cases she's making that yes innocent
people will go to jail but it's a lesser
of two evils it's worth the risk and so
because of this Wallace is happening
Thanos is quite literally showing all
this infighting to counter sims because
Connor Sims is of such a mind right now
because of the things that he's done
he's convinced that no one will believe
him and Thanos feeds on that he says
look I mean they're fighting amongst
themselves they can't even agree on how
to save the world
what makes you think they're going to
agree that you're telling the truth
about eternity being confined in Chains
you know and so Connor Sims again is a
little unsure about a situation but he
says he knows is the only way for them
to know the truth it's for you to show
them the truth and so what happens is he
basically escapes from his cell and he
allows his power to just explode not
having a sense of you know of maximum
capacity if he did that he would
probably destroy the universe but he
allows his power to explode to an extent
that it basically overrides the energies
of the Triskelion basically shutting it
down the reason why he does this is
because this cell that he's confined in
was designed explicitly to keep his
powers in check the issue with this is
that no one knew how powerful he was
when Adam Brashear had faced off against
an T man he had an idea of how powerful
he was but he was really fighting an T
man on the atomic level as opposed to
fighting him on the level of power that
he possessed and so because of this we
didn't know what it was that he was
capable
and with an embrasure not knowing the
full extent of counter sims powers it
came to fruition that counter sims just
broke out of his cell and so because of
the fact that he broke out of his cell
because of the fact that the
confinements of Thanos were no longer
powered he was able to break out of his
containment unit and basically start
wreaking havoc within the Tris kinda
this is one of the best parts of the
whole story this is amazing because this
is classic Thanos I mean when people
think of Thanos this is what they think
of Dallas with the Infinity Gauntlet
school Thanos with the ol cosmic cubit
school the best Thanos is Thanos when
he's cornered is when he when he
basically has to fight his way out
that's the best Thanos not only because
of the fact that he's so capable in
terms of his abilities but because of
the fact that he is he's ruthless and
he's intelligent and so again he
basically begins to tell us here or at
least when the ultimate show up he go -
Connor Sims now a couple things to point
out here is that the powers of the
ultimate complement one another what I
mean by this is that at one point in the
history of her character a Carol Danvers
went by the name of binary whereby she
was able to absorb cosmic energies or
absorb any kind of energy and then
channel those back out as cosmic
energies now in truth this was just
Chris Claremont's way of trying to
reinvent her character Thor on the x-men
team and hope it would boost her
popularity it really didn't hurt her
comics were just routinely cancelled and
what we're seeing right now with all-new
all-different marvel is about a
successful as she's been since her run
and Marvel now when she officially
became Captain Marvel but before that
she really was not a very successful
character people knew who she was but
she couldn't hold a title to save her
life and so what ultimately happens here
is Adam Brashear uses his energies to
manipulate positive matter channels them
into Carol Danvers and she basically now
has cosmic level powers the kicker about
this is that it doesn't matter with a
nose Thanos is still able to take her
out not only that she's able to use her
energies to channel them into spectrum
in order to allow spectrum who is
basically living energy to go into the
mind of Thanos and try to override his -
it was a little bit like a chain
reaction atom brashear feeds Carol
Danvers who in turn feeds spectrum but
when spectrum enters the mind of Thanos
she realizes that his mental energies
are way too much for her to be able to
cope with they're beyond a level she can
even begin to comprehend and that's true
this character oh you ain't snot
retconning anything here it's always
been that way
else's mental energies his mental powers
you know not necessarily telepathy
different things like that but just the
abilities that he's capable of by using
his mind have always been his greatest
feat his intelligence so on and so forth
when spectrum goes into his mind she's
literally overwhelmed and he in turn
takes the energy that was being pushed
into him by spectrum and sends that
energy back out and she said add at Adam
Brashear so it's like this giant circle
you know Adam Bashir charges Carol
Danvers new charges spectrum who forces
her energies onto Thanos who in turn
takes those energies and shoots an
overseer now the reason why this is an
important thing when it comes to Thanos
is because he always is at the top of
his game when it comes to battle
actually because of the fact that he
realized that Adam Bashir was the one
who is making all of this possible in
the first place
taking him out me is that Carol Danvers
would not be in her position of binary
and it also means that spectrum wouldn't
be nearly as powerful now the funny
thing about all this is that T'Challa is
watching all this unfold now in terms of
his intelligence T'Challa is pretty
smart now I would say he's probably
smarter than tano's just because of the
fact that when it comes to the top you
know five smartest people in the Marvel
Universe
danos ranks it like number six or number
seven Black Panther is in the top three
as far as I'm aware and so because of
this Black Panthers just kind of
watching things unfold but even while
The Ultimates are doing the best they
can to face off against him danos is
just trashing him he's trashing of all
one by one
and this just shows you how capable he
is that he's going against America
Chavez who can open portals she can feed
off energy he's going toe to toe with
Adam Brashear who's literally a guy that
can manipulate particles neo he's going
against Carol Danvers who strike those
on par with the Incredible Hulk and
arrested form I mean he's going against
everybody and doing his own and so
because of the fact that the charla is
so intelligent he comes to the
realization that they can't fight Thanos
with brute force there's no way they're
going to stand a chance if Thanos can
stand toe-to-toe with the Incredible
Hulk they can't beat him and so the only
way to defeat him is to use their minds
to use their wits and do the best they
can and so what happens here is they
basically shut off access to his mind
they more or less use a mental
projection or a user use mental energies
the kind of energies that were designed
to keep Connor Sims contained and they
in turn project those in mental energies
into Thanos and quite literally sever
the I guess electronic synopses they
basically shut off his brain's ability
to function is essentially what they do
now under normal circumstances in
T'Challa
tells us this under normal circumstances
shutting off the brain of tano's would
have killed him but as we know he's been
barred from the realm of mistress death
and so he's basically just in a
catatonic state now this is al Ewing
saving Thanos this is basically him just
saying hey we're going to use him later
on we're not gonna remove this piece
from the chessboard yet because he's too
good you know he's not necessarily the
queen but he's certainly a bishop or a
rook and so we're not going to remove
him yet because he's a guy that we need
to use later on now this will probably
feed into some massive crossover event
because as most any Marvel fan will tell
you for those of you guys who were new
as most any veteran Marvel comic fan
will tell you if there's any one person
in the cosmos to have on your team when
it comes to matters of intelligence
Thanos is one of the guys that you want
in your corner I mean the Oh perfect
case scenario you've got Thanos and
Galactus and all the cosmic entities you
know but if I had to pick one Thanos
would be my guy just because of his
experience because of what he's capable
of and so because of this you know the
The Ultimates initially go back to
bickering with one another they go back
to arguing with one another but
following Thanos attacking The Ultimates
require to him attacking The Ultimates
Connor Sims had just taken off and so we
didn't really know where he had went to
we didn't really know what had happened
with him but then what we do is we
transition to him as things begin to
wrap up and we find that he had just
kind of traveled into deep space and
he's taking some time to think about
everything that's going on but he's also
overwhelmed by the gravity of things
because in the mind of Connor Sims Civil
War 2 is happening the superheroes are
fighting on planet earth because some
inhuman can see the future but for him
he's like there's much bigger things to
worry about like there was a threat out
there to the universe likely even to the
multiverse and so it was like why are
you fighting over this this is more or
less the civil war - equivalent to
annihilation from Civil War 1 and what I
mean by that is those you guys who don't
know while the Civil War one event was
taking place with Captain America and
Tony Stark fighting one another the
villain annihilist had discovered the
negative zones equivalent of the power
cosmic the energy that Galactus wields
and Annihilus had invaded the earth-616
universe and was literally cutting a
swath through the universe I mean just
wiping out planet after planet this is
wiping out life all over the place it
was really like guerrilla warfare
tactics it was last battle at the Alamo
it was the the various cosmic forces
doing the best they could to just
survive and the heroes on earth were
fighting about superhuman Registration
that's basically what's happening with
this story right now
that's what al Ewing seems to be leading
up to that's one reason why I love the
ultimate so much because it's a huge
cosmic event that's going on out here
while they're just fighting about Civil
War - it's really setting the landscape
for much bigger things and so as it
begins to fall through these dimensional
doorways he begins to recall on things
this question is what happened here what
being exists out there that possesses
such incredible power that they're able
to completely take over and to chain the
universe itself here because in the mind
of Connor Sims with his experience
throughout the multiverse his experience
traveling outside of all space and time
the only people capable of doing this
are like the living tribe deal and the
one above all but apparently not
apparently somebody else is able to do
that we know it's not the molecule man
Owen Reese or at least it doesn't seem
to be that way but as he continues to
fall down through things because his
power is on such an extreme degree if
there was anyone that could face off
against this multiversal being that's
capable of attaining eternity it would
probably be Connor Sims but Connor Sims
going outside and battling this this
entity would probably result in the
destruction of the multiverse not only
that Galactus was tasked by eternity to
make sure no one knew what was going on
now why attorney who did that we don't
know and so in response to Connor Sims
falling through you know these
dimensional barriers and falling outside
of all existence Galactus retrieves him
and Galactus transforms him into his new
Herald not only that what he also says
is go get the Ultimates
go find me the Ultimates because I'm
going to make them heralds as well and
this is basically just Galactus building
an army for himself using his power
cosmic
it's him creating what looks like it's
going to be six different heralds for
the purpose of leading a campaign
against whatever this multiverse allure
this omnipotent being happens to be that
managed to chain up eternity
okay so I absolutely love Ultimates like
it's it's I think really one of the
standout titles and all-new
all-different marvel and Marvel now 2.0
the sad thing is that like not a lot of
people know about it or they don't know
what's going on in it and so because
that they're just like missing out on
this amazing stuff so I'm really hoping
this video will serve the purpose of
letting you guys know what's going on
and you guys will go out and buy it
because it is an awesome title so for
those of the guys who were curious about
like cosmic Marvel about like eternity
and Galactus and all that kind of stuff
this takes care of all that Ultimates
covers all that we've covered all the
ultimate stuff up to this point but it
covers all that but the big question
that people have had is who chained
eternity that was the big question we
saw in all-new all-different Ultimates
that somebody had basically put eternity
the living embodiment of the multiverse
in Chains now what al Ewing is doing
here is actually offered a little bit of
a change with regards to the Eternity
concept and we'll get to that once we
get further into this video because what
we're basically going to get is the
origin of everything that's ever existed
in Marvel Comics from the time the very
first universe took form up until the
collapse of the multiverse now and what
not really what happened but in terms of
some of the history of the various
different multiverses that have existed
in between so it'll all make sense by
the time we get to it I won't be
confusing in any way but the idea here
is that we initially pick up with Adam
Brashear with blue Marvel basically it
is kind of like you know staring into
you and trying to figure out what's
going on with everything because
remember the Ultimates basically
disbanded during the events of Civil War
- when Carol Danvers was using the
Ultimates as a way to basically carry
out her goal of keeping crime from
happening before it happened of course
Ulysses and all that kind of good stuff
but because of the fact that that a lot
of people hated Civil War - but what a
Ewing ended up doing was basically
bringing the Ultimates back together to
answer the question of who chained
eternity and it was only when the
Ultimates had learned this had happened
they began to ask the question of what
was going on now from this point we
transition over to over to Monica
Rambeau
and the funny thing about Monica Rambeau
is spectrum is that historically she's
played a lot of different roles I mean
she's been captain universe I believe I
want to say she was Captain Marvel at
one point
um but the whole idea here I think she
was captain universe I think she was
just Captain Marvel um I think it was
I'm confusing her with the girl from
Hickman's Avengers of New Avengers the
random chick who was in a car wreck and
and suddenly saved by the symptoms of
the universe
became captain universe will cover that
next to you but Monica Rambo's played
Captain Marvel for a time and and the
whole idea is that she was always kind
of considered to be a throwaway
character by a lot of readers in the
sense that she never really received her
time in the Sun and the cool thing about
this is that she actually gets it
because what al viewing has really been
harping on with her character is how
powerful she is that she is in effect
pure energy that the physical body that
we see is not her true form that Adam
Brashear looks at her and sees her for
what she really is which is basically
just pure energy in the form of a human
meaning she can basically do anything
now we kind of knew that with her
character to a degree in a sense because
she was able to manipulate all facets of
the energy spectrum she could turn into
anything any form of energy she could
use any form of energy that kind of
thing come on I mean she can't like warp
reality on a universal scale like she
can't manipulate molecules or anything
like that she's effectively just a giant
battery and so it's really really cool
to see what kind of limits her powers
can be pushed to but again in the midst
of all this what is it up happening is
Monica's basically just kind of whisked
away and all of it seems to have been
done by Connor Sims now again Connor
Sims as we know him is basically an T
man of course we covered him during the
the origin story of blue Marvel but he
had since been turned into a Herald of
Galactus and the reason why was because
a Galactus realizes that eternity had
been chained but not knowing who it was
that did it basically said if there is a
being out there that can chain eternity
then I need a new Herald and that Herald
is going to go to the ultimate bring the
Ultimates to me and make them my heralds
and so the idea of Galactus was to use
the ultimate asses heralds essentially
functioning as protectors of the
universe the way it existed now and
that's exactly what happens the various
Ultimates are basically whisked away by
Connor Simms to Galactus ship tattoo and
they're met with America Chavez who
basically says look there is a mass of a
massive threat coming and we have to
find a way to deal with this now America
Chavez is one of these characters who's
only ever really as interesting as a
story that she's in she's not inherently
interesting by herself we know this
because ultimate like America number one
came out sold really well and then
America number two tanks so she's just
not really an interesting character but
for what she does here in the Ultimates
this makes her interesting and that's
why I say and Marvel Comics a lot of the
characters are not inherently intriguing
it's the events surrounding them that
make them intriguing for example Captain
universe is not an intriguing character
it's Hickman's Avengers and New Avengers
that make make a captain universe
intriguing the same thing with star
brand a night mask and a lot of those
characters it's the events going on
around them that make them interesting
as opposed to just the characters
themselves now of course America Chavez
being here is basically saying there's
something wrong with the multiverse
there's some threat out there in the
multiverse that's screwing everything up
and we are going to have to try to find
a way to essentially fix it now of
course the other half of this is that
Galactus and Connor Sims basically take
off and they actually end up meeting
directly with the linee tribunal and
master order and Lord chaos now the
reason why this happens is because of
the fact that we'd seen this before in
the previous discussion of that the
previous videos that we've done that the
first problem the ultimate solved is
basically solving all the problems in
the universe
the first POW a major problem they
solved was a Galactus they looked at
Galactus and they said him being the
devourer of worlds is a threat to all
life in existence what we're going to do
is we're basically going to evolve him
into his perfect form and make him the
life bringer now the reason why Galactus
being made the life bringer was such a
huge deal in terms of the contents of
this story is that from the perspective
of master order and Lord chaos they
represent opposing size right I mean
we've had this discussion countless
times and we'll have this discussion
again when we basically remaster
Infinity Gauntlet and when we do
infinity war and all that cosmic stuff
next year the whole idea is that the
universe is basically in balance there
is order and there's chaos and you can't
have one without the other a perfectly
ordered universe would look crazy
a perfectly chaotic universe would look
just as crazy jim Starlin showed us
those two things when we basically went
inside the minds of Thanos and Adam
warlock to see a perfect universe in
Adam warlocks mind and a chaotic
universe and Stannis's mind so because
of this they basically work in unison
the issue here is that in the mind in
the perspective of master order and Lord
chaos Galactus is supposed to be the
devourer of worlds that's his role in
the universe that's the role that he
plays in the same way that master order
an order and Lord chaos play the role of
two opposites with the in-betweener
being the reconciliation between order
and chaos in the same way that eternity
plays the role of being the living
embodiment of the universe and so on
Galactus is supposed to play the role of
the world of our now because of the fact
that he's not doing this they end up
invoking the Living Tribunal because
remember the Living Tribunal is
basically the judge whenever there's a
cosmic disagreement the Living Tribunal
invoked and the tribunal will determine
whether or not the actions of a being is
are basically in violation of cosmic
order which is to say if there were a
being that were nigh unstoppable that no
one could oppose in the Living Tribunal
would say this person is not part of the
cosmic order they're an aberration
they're a screw up that was the whole
thing with a character a protege who
basically copied the powers of everybody
that he saw and it made him Bert
virtually godlike to the point that even
protege was able to go again go toe to
toe with the Living Tribunal and so the
idea here is to basically have Galactus
on trial and say Galactus is supposed to
be the devourer of worlds if he's not
doing this he's not part of the cosmic
order he's not maintaining his rule he's
going against cosmic law ultimately the
Living Tribunal says no if this is going
to be the case with Galactus then this
is basically his perfect iteration this
is his perfect form he has moved in the
direction moved into his next stage of
evolution he's not violating any laws
now the issue that's made with this is
that the Living Tribunal also
establishes that because of the fact
that the all-new all-different marvel
universe and even multiverse is still
new that the cosmic law is still being
made the hierarchy is still being
constructed so for those of you guys who
were asking for a new hierarchy for
all-new all-different marvel a new
cosmic and power hierarchy we can't do
that yet because we don't know what the
hierarchy is and this plays out when
master order and lord chaos kill the
living tribunal now again because of the
fact that they kill the tribunal and
essentially take his place what they do
in turn is they move on and say we are
going to impose our will we're going to
impose our order on to everything we're
going to make the universe bend to our
will it's going to be how we believe it
should be it's going to function the way
that we think it should now in the midst
of all this we end up coming across some
sort of crazy enigmatic kind of energy
that makes its presence known to the
ultimates now of course as this energy
has fought by The Ultimates as his
energy begins to coalesce we end up
finding out that this energy is the
shaper of worlds now this is really kind
of cool
because the shaper of worlds is
basically a cosmic cube that went crazy
now the funny thing about this is that
the shaper of worlds cannot really do
anything on its own because it's a
cosmic cube a cosmic cube is basically
bound to the intention of the person who
wields it and so it would be like if I
gave you a pencil
all right the pencil can only do what
you do with it the pencil can't draw by
itself the pencil needs you to pick it
up and draw something on a piece of
paper and that's how a cosmic cube works
the cosmic you can't do anything
on its own this shaper of worlds is the
exact same way now what the shaper
basically tells us is that when it came
into existence in the Marvel Universe
before Secret Wars that it basically
functioned in all the ways that we saw
it do its whole thing that it would be a
villain it would show up it would do
some crazy things here and there but
when the collapse of the multiverse took
place the shaper of worlds was
effectively assured outside all space
and time and when it did it saw
something out there it's off force out
there that nobody knew about and so
because of that it basically confined
this confined him down to it to a
singular point where it more or less
drove him insane but it also made his
energy signature you know incorporeal
and so what it's been doing is basically
reconstituting itself down to a
recognizable form which isn't you know
then it turned harness by Adam Brashear
and The Ultimates more or less for
safekeeping and so because of the fact
that a Living Tribunal has essentially
been killed the first step of master
order and lord chaos is bonding
themselves into the being logos and then
to also try to basically force Galactus
back into being the devourer of worlds
in terms of them individually they're
not able to force Galactus back into the
position of being the devourer of worlds
and so for the most part they launch an
attack but nothing really happens
Galactus just fixes himself and then he
calls it a day but what al viewing also
does here is he invokes a guy by the
name of Jim Henson now Jim Henson is a
new creation he's something newly
introduced by Al Ewing and so was a lot
of the stuff that we're going to see
with a group called the Troubleshooters
and these are basically kind of recruits
that have been organized under Jim
Henson for the purpose of operating is
like a black ops team or like a recon
team and intelligence team now initially
Jim Henson is contacted by Phil Vaughn
of course we know him as the government
only the liaison who's been tasked with
monitoring the Ultimates of course the
reason why the government did that is
because of the amount of power the
Ultimates possess and the idea that they
were basically running around in space
without anybody keeping an eye on them
and so what this does is this basically
reveals to us that both Phil vaad and
Jim Henson were part of a group called
the first Eternity battalion now we're
not gonna learn a whole lot about them
but we're gonna learn a little bit more
here and a little here a little while
just enough to kind of give us some
context and that's really about it and
it makes sense just because these are
characters that are being introduced it
would really be way too much information
if we got origin stories for all these
guys over the course of a six-issue
story or just it'd be way too long the
way too convoluted way too confusing
anyways
throw everybody off and so we're
basically just kind of given this a
little bit of information about Jim
Henson but the idea here is that from
Phil Watts perspective Jim Henson as
well as this guy Simon Razvi which we'll
learn about him here in a minute
um the idea is that because the
Ultimates are more or less running
around with any without anybody keeping
an eye on them and because of the fact
that they basically disbanded and then
reformed against the wishes of the
federal government the Troubleshooters
are being sent in to monitor the
ultimate secretly to investigate their
base of operations to make sure they're
not up to anything nefarious and to also
essentially bring them in and say you
guys are not supposed to be banded
together you guys have to answer to the
government in terms of why you're doing
this now jumping back to master order
and lord chaos again because of the fact
that they failed in their attempts to to
force Galactus back into his normal
state we end up having Connor Sims
whisked away by Galactus as soon as the
Living Tribunal died basically the like
just said okay things are popping off
things are going crazy get out of here
go get the ultimate to tell them what's
going on that was one of the coolest
moments was literally basically just
kind of whisked him away because that's
when you know that things were getting
incredibly serious and that's the
coolest thing is because Galactus is
such an imposing character in Marvel
Comics such a powerful character in
Marvel Comics that when he's with his
Herald and things begin to sort of panic
you can almost kind of see him looking
at the situation a little fearful and
just kind of whispering - Connor Sims
look man go tell the Ultimates what's
going on before things are too late and
like whisking the ultimate you know
whisking him away to go find the
ultimate so it's really cool because
it's a great way to show us the gravity
of the situation now because master
order and Lord chaos were unable to
force their their power onto onto
Galactus they travel to the in-between
and remember the in-betweener was
created by master order in Lord chaos
for the purpose of basically having a
balance of physical representation of
the balance between order and chaos but
by absorbing the in-betweener into them
and then with with master order
absorbing you know Lord chaos into
himself what basically ends up happening
here is we end up having a new leaf or a
newly created being formed called logos
and this is really kind of a cool idea
because now what it gives us is a new
cosmic entity and it's actually pretty
interesting because the first thing this
cosmic entity does is it looks around
and it says all these Celestials and so
on and so forth they're all aberrations
they're all things that do not need to
exist they're held there holdovers from
the way things used to be a new order
maintain a new universe has been created
and the cosmic landscape must reflect
this new universe and so what happens is
logos obliterates every last one of the
Celestials save for one and the one
celestial that is saved is essentially
the one above all of the of the
Celestials now this brings into sharp
relief the question of the one overall
how does a function this is a super
simple answer there's two versions of
the one above all there is the god of
the Marvel multiverse the one that we
tried to kill and failed and then
there's the one above all celestial
they're two distinctly different beings
don't worry people get them confused all
the time so it's cool don't don't sweat
it if you're kind of a little thrown off
by it you're not the only one a lot of
folks kind of get thrown off by that but
we'll just call him the top celestial
just for the sake of keeping things easy
even then this is really the only time
we see him but top celestial is
basically saved by the never Queen now
the never Queen was actually a Dan Slott
creation as far as I'm aware and she
originally appeared in Silver Surfer but
the never Queen was really more of like
a plot device that Dan Slott made but
because she was established to be a
cosmic entity she's basically been ruled
over and all the other stories that
involved cosmic entities but the never
Queen basically exists outside of all
things that currently exist and she
represents things that could possibly
exist so again we're really getting into
the realm of hypotheticals so on and so
forth but because of the fact that
everything happening in the universe is
taking place in the present she's always
one step ahead she's always in the
future she always represents the
possibility of what could be so the
never Queen is composed of the
possibility of you going left instead of
going right the never Queen is composed
of the possibility of you waking up
instead of dying
she's just composed of all the
possibilities that could exist that's
what makes up who she is so again it's
kind of crazy but it but she fits
perfectly into the realm of abstract
characters now the problem with this is
that in the midst of the Troubleshooters
residing inside the base of operations
for the Ultimates their presence
culminates in the Ultimates arriving to
see them there and so what is it
happening is the Ultimates face off
against the Troubleshooters and it's
kind of a cool conflict to see it's not
wildly significant but it's cool to see
their various counter balances but what
is up happening here is Jim Henson keeps
tapping it as something called the sigh
force now we don't know a whole lot
about what the sigh force is we simply
just know that it's there but the big
guy who's really important to focus on
here is Ross whoa this
I initially goes against blue Marvel
Adam Brashear and then easily overpowers
him and the biggest question to ask here
is that if Adam Brashear is one of the
most powerful beings in existence in
Marvel Comics then how much more
powerful could Rosco really be if he's
going to overpower Adam Brashear in his
entirety so again what seems to be the
indication is that this Rosco guy is a
guy who's not supposed to be here ed
he's someone who's a bit of an
aberration he's a guy that's not what he
appears to be and so again in the middle
of this battle between The Ultimates and
the trouble shooters logo's returns to
Galactus and forces him back into being
the devourer of worlds and when I first
read this I was just like wow like it
blew my mind because logos is basically
like you're going to go back to being
who you were whether you want to be or
not and so it was kind of this impurity
that spilled all over Galactus and one
of the final words he says is I hunger
now the depiction of Galactus as he
appears here in terms of how he's drawn
is designed to be that way he looks
screwed up he looks wrong he looks
corrupted that's exactly how it's
supposed to be that's how he's supposed
to appear simply because of the fact
that this is not his normal state he's
being forced back into an artificial
state because remember he basically
evolved into his next stage which was
the life bringer basically the ability
to create life as opposed to destroying
it though what also ends up happening
here is that Rosco emerges in the midst
of this fight with the ultimate and
basically becomes this sheer wrecking
force absolutely decimating every single
member of The Ultimates now of course
Galactus basically teleports back to
where everybody's located at what almost
immediately falls and so what we end up
finding out is that with regards to
Rosco being here with regards to you
know all these different things that are
going on with logos with master order
lord chaos all of this has basically
been implemented itself by something
called the first firmament and this is
when we start to get into the timeline
of things making sense now it kind of
boggled me a little bit because up until
this point in the story things seem very
disjointed all over the place and it was
a good read well I would rather have
this timeline you know at the beginning
of the story
that being said having it at the end
actually makes it a little more
impactful just because of the fact that
it gives us all the answers that we've
been looking for all this time and so
what happens as Al Ewing goes all the
way back to the very beginning of all
things now
in Marvel Comics we knew this was the
case right like you know before Secret
Wars you had
Marvel the multiverse all that kind of
stuff the universe that you think of
when you think of Marvel's so when
Spiderman first appeared when the
Incredible Hulk first appeared Iron Man
all that kind of good stuff of course we
had the universe that Galactus hailed
from the multiverse that I guess really
the universe before the current version
of the multiverse and then we had you
know all these different universes and
so on and so forth dating back to the
point when the very first universe came
into existence somewhere along the line
in Marvel Comics what we end up finding
out here is that this being the first
firmament basically created life as the
singular representation of the very very
first universe the firmament made a
group called the aspirants and what Al
Ewing is drawing on here is he's
actually drawing on Karen Gillan I think
it is his run of Iron Man which was
absolutely amazing but one of the things
that curing Gillan established was that
at some point in the history of the
universe that there were a massive
number of Celestials but there was a war
that had broken out between the
Celestials and the aspirants now we
didn't know what the aspirants look like
we didn't know their history all we knew
is that they were just some group with
power equal to that of the Celestials
and it resulted in the astronaut aching
the Celestials pushing them to the brink
of almost complete and total extinction
in an act of desperation the Celestials
created something called the God killer
armor and the god killer armor basically
obliterated the aspirants and pushed
them to the brink of all destruction now
that is the most recent version of the
Marvel Universe so we'll call that the
seventh Marvel multiverse in this first
Marvel multiverse what we're seeing here
right now this is basically just a war
that broke out between the asteroids and
the Celestials which is always destined
to do but in this war that initially
broke out it led to the destruction of
that universe and when the universe was
reborn as the second universe the the
first firmament basically spread out and
so what we basically get up to this
point is that there was a singular
universe with the destruction of the of
the first universe it exploded into a
multiverse and so with the creation of
this multiverse came that cosmic
entities that we know that eternity and
so on and so forth and so because of
that in this basically this second
multiverse things progressed the wars
repeated yet again the war between the
aspirants the war between the Celestials
it kept happening over and over and over
again throughout every single multiverse
that was created up to the seventh
multiverse which went into secret Wars
which went into the 8th multiverse as we
have it right now but despite all the
different conflicts that had happened
the first firmament was always in the
back this energy force was just always
in the back watching everything unfold
and the first firmament was plotting its
revenge was plotting its way to
basically eliminate all things in
existence we take the universe back unto
itself and then be the sole universe in
existence basically consolidating
everything back down and so because of
this the first firmament began to launch
a series of campaigns aimed at basically
destabilizing all things in existence
and trying to create aberrations that
would make eternity extremely weak due
to the fact that following the new
formation of the universe or the
multiverse eternity was already in a
weakened state so it would allow the
allow the first storm into basically
overpower eternity put it in Chains and
then begin the process of destroying
everything now the reason why I say that
al Ewing is basically going through and
offering changes is because historically
speaking in Marvel Comics eternity was
the physical representation of a
universe and so there were an infinite
number of eternity zhh one for each
universe the idea had been tried with
that there was a singular eternity that
made up the multiverse but there was
nothing to indicate that it was actually
true what al viewing is doing here is
making it true al Ewing is saying now
there's a multiversal eternity there's
one eternity that represents or is the
physical embodiment of the multiverse
inside that multiversal eternity are all
the infinite number of universes and one
eternity for each of those universes so
again it's a little interesting you know
at the very least but again it basically
expands the Marvel cosmology now of
course switching back to the conflict as
it exists right now of course what we
end up doing is we end up having Connor
Sims basically resurrected by the
combined efforts of Monica Rambeau and
Adam Brashear and so because of the fact
that Connor Sims is brought back a
Connor Sims basically containing what's
left of the life bringer energy
essentially takes himself directly to
Galactus and merges himself with
Galactus to a degree in the sense that
he disperses himself into Galactus as a
result Galactus is reborn as the life
bringer and then destroys rot slow and
in doing so learns everything that Ross
foe knows which is basically the first
firmament the idea that this first
firmament has struck first that this
entire event everything we've seen up to
this point is the first battle it's the
opening salvo it's the first skirmish
and the first firmament intends to
launch a massive campaign against the
entire multiverse destroying essentially
everything I'm bringing
all things into existence back into
itself and then being a singular
universe unto itself going forward
okay so getting into this newest story
of The Ultimates a lot of people have
been asking me to cover this the biggest
problem is that Marvel releases their
stories monthly so we've had to wait
like four or five or six months for this
story to finish before we could cover it
that's what's so irritating about the
way Marvel publishes right now because
DC has spoiled me so bad DC releases
bi-weekly for like their most popular
titles and so by the time a story comes
to an end I actually have to go back and
read it again because I usually forget
what happened at the very beginning but
what this story is is basically
something called eternity work and this
focuses on the idea of what is quite
literally a battle of cosmic entities
now what this also does is it requires
us to understand like the new Marvel
cosmic hierarchy and the way the
multiverse works fortunately you'll find
a link down in the description to that
video that I made quite some time ago
and it basically runs over the new
multiverse and all that kind of good
stuff now to brush back up on that for
those of you guys who just don't have
the time or the inclination to watch it
the long and short of it is that Marvel
with The Ultimates line of stories
introduced something called the first
firmament and what they told us is that
in the very beginning of all things
there was just this singular universe
and this universe was sentient every
universe has been sentient so if the
universe could get up and walk around it
would be the first firmament now the
first firm had created life in the form
of beings called the Celestials and most
people know who the Celestials are by
this point they're just these super
powerful beings that are basically
responsible for creating life and
different things like that but the
Celestials that were created by the
firmament existed in two forms those who
were faithful to the firmament and those
who were not those who were faithful
were called the aspirants those who were
not were just called Celestials now what
this did is it basically led to this
massive war like this this giant civil
war among these beings that had enough
power to basically control and
manipulate all of reality itself and so
like you would expect this war quite
literally laid waste to the universe and
what ended up happening is like you
picking up a glass cup and dropping it
on the ground the universe completely
shattered now of course what this did is
all these different shattered pieces
became universes of their own and that
was the explanation of how the
multiverse came into existence now for
reasons that are never explained that
multiverse was destroyed
and then recreated and destroyed and
recreated and destroyed and recreated so
on and so forth
leading all the way up to Jonathan
Hickman's collapse of the multiverse and
Avengers and New Avengers and in the
start of all-new all-different marvel
but what Ultimates does in the all-new
Milan all-new all-different marvel line
of comics is it gives us the first
firmament as this being this basically
existed outside of all time and space
and is finally making its return but the
reason why this matters is because we're
talking about a level of power so
extreme that the first firmament was
actually able to quote-unquote chain up
the multiverse now this is when we start
getting into like ad abstract things for
the most part when it comes to comics
things are really easy to understand
when people are able to just kind of
crack open a comic and read what's going
on mostly because of the fact that when
the average person goes and reads a
comic book it's easy to digest The
Incredible Hulk is pissed off The
Incredible Hulk is gonna smash stuff
that's super simple but when it comes to
like cosmic entities we're dealing with
AB stretch we're dealing with a level of
power so extreme that it can literally
result in the destruction of all things
in existence and that's what I want you
to keep in the back of your head what
we're gonna be seeing over the course of
this story is a level of power among
these beings that's so insane that if
one of them were to lose it it would
destroy all things in existence well
except for the Ultimates we'll talk
about them here in a second but that's
basically what this is it's a fight for
all existence the way this opens up is
with Galactus the life bringer now
remember if you're catching up on this
if you haven't seen any of the Ultimates
videos that we've done so far
Galactus has always been the world
devourer that was always his thing he
would travel across the cosmos he would
consume worlds that were able to sustain
life he would keep his energies in check
and that was really it with all-new
all-different marvel the first thing the
team of The Ultimates did was band
together and then basically transformed
Galactus into the life bringer so that
he would no longer be a threat to the
universe instead he would be a force for
good instead of a force for destruction
now of course this Saint Galactus on the
path of going through and just like
recreating worlds that he'd previously
consumed any number of things that like
a super hero with that insane level of
power would possibly do the problem with
this is that once Galactus learned that
the first firmament had basically
returned and this being was of such an
extreme level of power that it was able
to basically chain up the multiverse
Galactus panic now if that does not give
you an indication of how
the first firmament is I don't know what
will because keep in mind with the power
of Galactus he can create life he can
end life he can manipulate the universe
itself I mean he's just a being really
one of the most powerful beings in
existence out there but the idea is that
Galactus had basically been trying to
fight off as best he can and literally
running for his life in almost every
conceivable situation because he'd been
confronted by these beings that were
working for the first firmament that
were equal or superior to his own power
and so what he ended up doing was
actually taking up refuge in a place
that was basically rated by the molecule
man Owen Reese now remember the molecule
man basically sat alongside classic Reed
Richards
Franklin Richards and those guys and
they were the ones creating the new
universes in all-new all-different
marvel the idea who is that because the
molecule man was so insane in terms of
his abilities he also created kind of
like this pocket universe for himself
and it was a place for him to just kind
of hang out and kind of reside now of
course what were told by Galactus is
that molecule man had long since
abandoned this place we don't know where
he went to you we have no idea what ever
happened to him he had basically just
taken off and so because of this
Galactus basically co-opted this pocket
dimension for himself and then actually
once he emerges he's on the planet of
ego now ego is kind of a weird situation
because in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
which is how most people are being
introduced to his character he is pretty
different than he is in Marvel Comics in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe Marvel
calls him a celestial he's actually not
he's literally just a guy uh who had
tried to save his planet from a Sun that
was going supernova he ultimately failed
and he actually merged with all the
people on his planet and the planet
itself
and that's why he's called ego the
Living Planet now the funny thing about
this is that ego hates Galactus and the
reason for this as crazy as it sounds is
because when Galactus and ego first
fought Galactus actually attached a
rocket to his back-end and sent him
hurtling through space that's exactly
what happened that's when he learned the
whole origin story of ego the problem
with this is that as powerful as ego is
he's only ever really powerful on his
own on his home planet it would be like
if you had the ability to control
whatever was at your home did if your
home could get up and walk around and
control whatever it was that you wanted
it to do
egos like that with his home planet so
ego for example cannot control earth
with Galactus arriving here because of
the fact that he's exhausted with his
own
he's not necessarily able to overpower
ego instead it actually turns into
really more of a diplomatic mission and
the reason for this is because Galactus
is travelling around the cosmos and
assembling a team of some of the most
powerful beings in existence the goal of
Galactus is to recruit ego to his side
as just one of many people who can pull
this off now
mystical act is perfectly aware of the
fact that none of these guys could
actually destroy the first firmament or
defeat them it's just a matter of is it
possible for them to so of course this
leads to to Galactus actually modifying
using his powers to modify ego the
Living Planet transform him into ego
crime so he's actually a full-bodied
entity which is cool because we've never
seen this before
not only that once ego is taken by
Galactus and brought to basically the
the Eternity watch is what they call
themselves
we end up having a lot of these beings
who are basically some of the most
powerful beings in existence now keep in
mind the cosmic entities as we think of
them the Celestials infinity these
characters they were all destroyed in
the last couple arcs that we covered so
if Galactus normally would have reached
out to them but they've all been
destroyed and so because of that it's
literally him grabbing whoever's left
now some of these characters are
extremely ambiguous like in Phenom for
example we don't know anything about it
but then there's people like the shaper
of worlds and there's the Sai hawk now
Sai Hawk is kind of a weird situation
because Sai Hawk was actually created by
a guy named Archie Goodwin back in 1986
and a series called SCI force that ran
for about three years now the idea is
that he actually hails from a comic line
called new universe which was relatively
popular at the time but never really
regained steam eventually Warren Ellis
tried to relaunch it with new Universal
but it's basically as close as we get to
the real world
if people develop powers the idea is
that the sidewalk the best example I can
use here and this is gonna be a
shameless example the best example I can
use here is like Captain Planet is
really yet you know when the Planeteers
combine their powers they get Captain
Planet when the members of the sci force
combine their powers they get SCI Hawk
that's it that's really all there is
it's just a being of insane psychic
power but again you know it's it's one
of those weird ambiguous scenarios which
is kind of thrown in here and rolled in
just because of the fact that Galactus
is reaching for whatever he can get and
so that's what these guys are they're
basically the leftovers that's really
the best way to call and they're just
kind of you know whatever it is that
they can do to try to
gave off this conflict but it's kind of
crazy because this takes the
annihilation / civil war concept and
expands it to a broader scale those of
you guys who don't know back when Marvel
launched the original civil war event
you know Captain America vs Iron Man
that was an earth-based conflict and
that was it it was strictly confined to
earth but while that conflict was going
on this villain Annihilus from the
negative zone had invaded the universe
and it was the craziest thing because
like Richard Ryder who was playing the
role of Nova at the time showed up on
earth and is like what are you guys
doing like the universe is about to be
overrun and destroyed what in the world
is going on like it was it was one of
the funniest things to happen there was
really kind of a cool moment but the
idea here is it is on a much broader
scale so while secret empires happening
and Hydra Captain America is like I'm
gonna make the world a better place like
all existence is on the brink of
complete and total collapse and so what
we end up doing here is we actually
transition and we end up finding out
that Galactus is not the only person
involved here there is another being who
is involved in trying to figure out a
way to keep this collapse of the
multiverse from happening and that this
being is actually Reed Richards also
known as the maker alongside the High
Evolutionary now we'll get into the High
Evolutionary Herbert Wyndham here in a
second but I want to talk about the
maker because the maker is really one of
the cooler characters that exists in
Marvel Comics but he's also a character
that Marvel's never really done a whole
lot with outside of the Ultimate
Universe in terms of him crossing over
and that makes sense because there was
never a reason for him to but the idea
is of the maker this version of Reed
Richards from the Ultimate Universe his
origin story is basically what you saw
in that terrible Fox film that has a
nine percent on Rotten Tomatoes which it
rightfully deserves except for Michael B
Jordan he was amazing but the idea is
that this version of Reed was very
similar to his main Marvel counterpart
in the sense that he was a genius he
became part of a think tank eventually
he branched off formed the Fantastic
Four so on and so forth the difference
here is that in 2009 Marvel launched an
event in the Ultimate Universe called
ultimatum and this event was basically
all of the superheroes in the Ultimate
Universe versus Magneto and it was
amazing I liked all to meet him a lot of
people hated it a lot of people did not
like ultimate him at all but I enjoyed
ultimatum it was kind of a cool thing
but this was one of those stories that
was designed to implement a paradigm
shift and one of the things that it saw
was basically read
Richards in the ultimate universe
falling from grace so to speak his
marriage proposal being rejected by
Susan storm so on and so forth and then
eventually becoming a bad guy and so
what this did is that he really
rechristened himself as the maker now it
also led him to things like children of
tomorrow which is kind of cool and
honestly I wouldn't mind covering that I
mean I always thought aspect to the
ultimate universe we're always kind of
fun and kind of interesting the problem
is that most people on my channel don't
really seem to care but it's kind of a
cool scenario because he was actually
one half of the equation when it came to
Jonathan Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers that came a point when ultimate
read actually joined the Cabal of Thanos
and trying to destroy different earths
across the multiverse but the idea here
is that the makers actually working
alongside Herbert Wyndham now the High
Evolutionary is actually a guy who
basically evolved his own molecular
structure he was obsessed with the idea
of human evolution now of course
modifying it among his own self he gave
himself basically godlike powers he is a
human being pushed to the extreme of
what humans will most likely become but
he also just kind of became this mad
scientist in the sense that he just kind
of hung out in wundagore mountain and he
basically just created like all these
different things he had like
counter-earth so on and so forth and
that's actually where these guys are
right now they are encounter earth
they're basically it's basically another
earth that's orbiting but that's kind of
the weird thing and that's the
disconnect because you'll never see
counter earth in any other stories in
Marvel Comics you will only see it in
this which is one of the big reasons why
people are just kind of like okay
continuities out the window and Marvel
because you would think that if there
was another earth orbiting around the
existing earth then somebody out there
would have noticed but it's kind of a
weird scenario because what they've
basically come to the conclusion of is
that with eternity quote-unquote
basically being chained by the first
firmament their goal is to essentially
grab all these different universes and
merge them into one now the belief is
that it will basically empower eternity
it'll make eternity more powerful than
it was before remember eternity is a
living embodiment of the universe and so
the idea is to merge all of these
universes into one and then feed that
energy directly into eternity giving it
the power to escape the first firmament
the problem with this is that we don't
know if it will really succeed and of
course it does to a degree but the issue
is that it actually coincides with the
maker in my evolutionary watchin all
these events unfold
gods to Galactus and his and his
eternity watch facing off against these
aspirants these faithful Celestials to
the first firmament itself and of course
where they do the best they can to face
off against these forces in the end it's
really not much of a battle because
we're talking about a conflict that is
extreme in the degree and so what we end
up doing is we actually transition to
black panther and to a place called the
necropolis now the crazy thing about
what Black Panther is doing is he's
actually being pretty dangerous when it
comes to the various gods and Marvel
Comics especially the Panther God the
being that basically provides Black
Panther with his various abilities the
Panther God is pretty selfish when the
Panther gods like look you will worship
me and no one else now with regards to
what Black Panther is doing the
necropolis was actually a concept that I
believe was created by Jonathan Hickman
and it was a way for a black panther to
actually talk to anyone who's ever been
a black panther in the history of
Wakanda basically him going to those who
have greater experience and who were
wiser than him but have long since
passed away and say what do you guys
think that I should do here now that fit
in nicely with the Black Panther concept
because it allowed to chala to basically
maintain the autonomy of what conduct
while also seeking outside counsel and
so reaching out to those who have
basically seen where these things will
reside or at the very least who have a
general idea of what the best road is to
take allows him to basically say look I
don't know everything that this this out
there I don't know everything that
exists I need your help in figuring
these things out again we'll talk more
about that once we get into Avengers and
new Avengers but the idea is that
because he cannot necessarily go to the
Panther God because they're kind of on
strenuous terms which are courses in his
own comic the idea is that instead he
reaches out to the tiger god and this is
kind of cool because it gives us all
these different Pantheon sees different
animal beings that exist out there but
the tiger God basically emerged when the
first beings came into existence and
while the tiger God does represent the
idea that humans were terrified of
Tigers you know back in the early days
it's also the idea that the tiger God
basically represents the very essence of
what it means for humans to feel fear it
is the the full culmination of
humanity's fear combined into a singular
being but the idea is that Black Panther
really kind of fights against the tiger
God for a second only to basically try
to use surface power now of course this
leads directly to the maker and the High
Evolutionary being successful in their
goal to channel all these universes
energies into
eternity and then ultimately free it but
it has a side effect of bringing in the
original Ultimates and that's where
people begin to look at these things now
something else that I want you to notice
here is that among these original
Ultimates is the ultimate Incredible
Hulk and that's why I say during the
events of secret Empire
that was not ultimate hulk that was just
regular Bruce Banner we know that
because he's in this story right now now
it also begs the question you know is
Marvel just kind of blowing you know
throwing continuity out the window which
they seem to be doing and is entirely
possible but the fact remains here that
because of the fact that these different
universes are all basically coalescing
into one another it allows you know
Galactus and his an eternity watch to
actually jump out of all space and time
so they're literally in this white space
they're outside of all things in
existence they can actually watch things
in existence take place now keep in mind
we're talking about beings who are of
the highest order so it's not like you
standing in Las Vegas and trying to see
what's happening in Los Angeles they
have this sort of multiversal cosmic
awareness and so they can stand outside
of the multiverse itself they can stand
outside of all things and still see
what's going on inside the idea here is
that again Galactus begins to hit home
at the concept that if the first Fermin
is not stopped that this first universe
isn't isn't halted did it'll result in
the destruction of all things in
existence which includes all the
remaining cosmic entities death so on
and so forth the cool thing about this
is that it also basically has the
Ultimates the the newest version of The
Ultimates facing off against their
previous their alternate reality
counterparts now the funny thing about
this is that people look at blue Marvel
atom brashear and in a lot of way she's
kind of a ride off now of course people
have recently on YouTube been talking
about him more and more but basically
blue Marvel is one of Marvel's versions
of Superman that's really it now he's
also a genius in a lot of different ways
but his power is not to be trifled with
and in this instance he knocks out
ultimate Hulk in one punch that's all it
takes he literally just uppercuts him in
the chin and that's the end of Ultimate
Hulk I mean he's just down now the idea
here is that because he's so empowered
and because he takes out the you know
ultimate Hulk so fast it immediately
catches the attention of the other
Ultimates the the original Ultimates now
of course they continue fighting on
until America Chavez basically says hey
look were the current Ultimates here in
this universe now it's basically the
Avengers from one universe leading the
Avengers from another universe and at
that point it just creates a cease fire
this classic Ultimates Captain America
basically saying everybody stop
everybody stand out if they are
effectively Avengers and we're basically
Avengers then we need to talk this out
and figure out what's going on
the problem with this is that by
combining their efforts together they
come to the realization that what a
maker did was by freeing eternity it
basically allowed eternity be consumed
by the first ferment to literally allow
the first formant to bolster its own
power and so inadvertently he actually
achieved the opposite of what he was
shooting for now none of this matters
anyway just because of the fact that the
maker as we see him here is just as
arrogant as he ever was when he was in
the Ultimate Universe and so because of
this it literally leads to him just
being destroyed by by spectrum this
living source of energy that's all she
is she's energy in physical form and
that's really all there is to it he gets
wiped out pretty fast now I would argue
the reason why this is done is because
of the fact that the maker is also still
going on in infamous Iron Man so again
this is the whole continuity thing this
is why these are getting kind of weird
for those guys had never read DCU this
is the problem people had when it came
to DC Comics characters appear in one
story they don't appear in the other
there's no continuity we don't know went
what story
when these stories take place if one
follows the other it gets really weird
and it gets really bonkers and it gets
really bananas but the idea here is
because of the fact that eternity has
been consumed by the first firmament the
goal of the Ultimates as they exist is
to combine a combination of their powers
as well as their brains to task and
actually jumpstart eternity again and
what this does is it brings him back not
only that because he's effectively
resurrected here it also brings about
the reintroduction of all these
different cosmic entities because
remember they are all effectively
children of eternity that's the way it
works when it came to Marvel Comics do
you have eternity the embodiment of the
universe and then like you know a man
and a woman giving birth to a kid
eternity just sort of popping out all
these cosmic entities different things
like that those Celestials who were
destroyed by the first firmament are
basically resurrected here they're
essentially brought back and so again
it's kind of eternity giving birth to
all these things bringing all these
entities back again and so because of
that we also end up finding out that the
queen of Nevers had actually taken the
last of the Celestials before they were
destroyed and so this one celestial that
did survive gave birth to even more
Celestials and so again it's basically
this
return to familiarity it's everything
resetting itself back to the way it was
before just by virtue of eternity
popping up so again it's really just
this idea that this being that literally
exists as the culmination of the
universe is returning the universe back
to the way that it's supposed to be now
of course things wrap up pretty fast
here and it's actually kind of
disappointing the way it wraps up so
fast the reason for this is because of
the fact that if you're not familiar
with what Marvel's doing right now
Marvel is basically doing legacy and
generations and the idea is there was so
much negative backlash to secret Empire
there was so much negative backlash to
Marvel basically switching characters
over are getting rid of classic
characters replacing them with new ones
the Marvel hit the panic button
and instead they said okay fine we need
to basically bring back everything the
way that it used to be and so this story
believe it or not this is actually
Ultimates to issue number 100 this is
legacy numbering what Marvel originally
wanted was ultimately issues 7 through
12 that's what the story was slated for
but because of the whole remembering
thing it's been shortened by two issues
and then in turn they've just tacked on
you know this ending sort of ramrodded
it into the conclusion of the story so
it was supposed to drag on longer as far
as I can tell but it's not so things
basically just end the first firmament
is just defeated right off the bat
that's really it and then that just kind
of brings it into the story things just
kind of get reset to normal and that's
that is this quick you know super into a
story that should have otherwise been
drawn out by a couple more issues and
actually probably would have had more of
a successful closure to it but the fact
remains with this particular thing it's
it's really just things going back to
normal to a degree Galactus still
remains a life bringer but again because
of the fact that this takes place before
the conclusion of secret Empire what it
does is it just shows the rest of the
the members of The Ultimates going
through and doing their own thing Carol
Danvers taking out Hydra black panther
going back to going back to what Conda
with the tiger God in his possession
presumably meaning that he's going to
start drawing his power from a new
entity but again it's one of these weird
scenarios because the story just kind of
ends it just kind of comes to a
conclusion but with that being said guys
we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comments explain it make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
robb core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah
I will catch you all later peace all
right so as promised our shout outs for
the producers of the comics explained
videos our patrons I want to give a
shout out to Jason see Austin s Jason s
Austin H Phillip and Austin B we have a
lot of Austin's and our patreon as well
as G gnosis 916 de gnosis didn't give us
the first and last name so we kinda had
to go with it I didn't mention your
all's last names after you guys didn't
want me to throw them out there but I
want to say thank you to you all by the
way your rob4 rings should be on their
way for our honor guard members of the
Rob core for these special patrons your
custom Rob core rings should be on their
way they're being shipped to me after
that I will have them shipped to you
stay tuned keep your eye on patreon and
your messages and you will hear about
them coming to you thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]